TO THAT.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IT IS.
MAY FIRST ALREADY.
WE ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND NORMALLY I DO
NOT LIKE TO START A SUBCOMMITTEE
WITHOUT. AT LEAST REPRESENTED
FROM EACH PARTY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE.
HAPPENING HERE.
I'M GONNA TAKE THERE ARE FOR
BILLS THAT ARE DEALING WITH THE
CURRENT SITUATION AROUND LEAD
BASED PAINT AND I'M GONNA. I'M
GONNA TAKE THOSE FIRST SO THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B..
TWENTY SEVENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH THREE AND.
I'VE NEVER EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE SO WE WILL MOVE
THROUGH THOSE THERE'S SOME
COMMONALITY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GET THOSE. DISPENSED WITH SO WHY
DON'T WE START WITH.
CHOOSE BILL I REMEMBER TO AB
TWENTY SEVENTY THREE. AND THEN
WE'LL GO THROUGH THE REST OF
THEM AND MISS IT YOU PERHAPS YOU
CAN.
I SOME OF THE SUB TOGETHER ALSO
FOR.
CERTAINLY OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES SO.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF A PACKAGE OF
BILLS TO ADDRESS A DECADES LONG
ATTEMPT BY SEVERAL TOXIC LEAD
PAINT COMPANIES.
TO ESCAPE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
POISONING GENERATIONS OF
CHILDREN WITH THEIR PRODUCTS.
AND BY WAY BACKGROUND FOR MANY
DECADES THERE WERE A HANDFUL OF
GIANT PAINT MANUFACTURERS IT
SOLD TOXIC LEAD PAINT
THE CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS.
THESE COMPANIES DID THIS KNOWING
THE RISK TO HUMAN LIFE
BRAIN DAMAGE KIDNEY DAMAGE
INFERTILITY. REDUCED ACCUSED
DISAPPEARED ABOUT MENTAL
DISORDERS AND EVEN DEATH.
MANY OF US HER PARENTS WE KNOW
THAT CHILDREN ARE PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO LEAD POISONING
THIS
IT'S AN ISSUE I STARTED LEARNING
ABOUT AS I WATCH MY TWO YEAR OLD
SON.
NOT ON OUR WINDOW SILL AT HOME.
OVER THE YEARS AREN'T THESE
COMPANIES MAINLY VIEWED THIS
ISSUE AS A PROBLEM PARTICULAR TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THERE ARE.
INTERNAL COMPANY RECORDS THAT
DESCRIBE THE ISSUE AS A PR
PROBLEM NOT A THREAT TO PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR EXAMPLE. A NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX LEAD PAINT INDUSTRY
MEMO DESCRIBED QUOTE A PUBLICITY
PROBLEM CONCENTRATED QUOTE IN
NEGRO AND PART RICAN FAMILIES.
BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS OF THESE
COMPANIES CHILDREN POISONED
CHILDREN WERE SPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO LEAD POISONING.
IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND TEN
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTING MANY OF THIS
JURISDICTIONS ARE THAT SIT ON
THIS JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
INCLUDING MY CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. SUIT THREE PAINT
COMPANIES SHORT WILLIAMS CONAGRA
AND AND L. INDUSTRIES WHICH BY
THE WAY STANDS FOR NATIONAL
LEAD.
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO EIGHTEEN
YEARS LATER.
THE TRIAL COURT FOUND IN AN
APPELLATE COURT AFFIRMED THAT
THE TOXIC PAINT COMPANY'S
NEGLIGENCE CREATED A WIDESPREAD
PUBLIC NUISANCE WHICH THE
COMPANIES MUST PAY TO ABATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE THREE
COMPANIES ARE STILL TRYING TO
ESCAPE LIABILITY TODAY AND.
WE HAVE AT THIS TIME A HALF A
DOZEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO'VE
INTRODUCED BILLS TO ENSURE THAT
THE JUDGMENT IS CARRIED OUT. THE
PAINT COMPANIES ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND OUR NEXT
GENERATION OF KIDS IS PART ARE
PROTECTED FROM LEAD PAINT.
MY BILL AB TWENTY SEVENTY THREE.
ATTACKS HOMEOWNERS FROM
POTENTIALLY FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
THAT THE PAINT COMPANIES HAVE
SUGGESTED THEY MIGHT BRING. IF A
HOMEOWNER PARTICIPATES IN THE
ABATEMENT PROGRAM CALLED FOR BY
THE RESOLUTION OF THIS LAWSUIT.
ANY POLITICIAN THERE WERE TWO
SENTENCES IN A ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE PAGE DECISION THAT
SUGGESTED THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE TOXIC LEAD PAINT COMPANIES
MIGHT SUE A HOMEOWNER. FOR
MERELY PARTICIPATING IN AN
ABATEMENT PROGRAM.
ANY HOMEOWNER WHO DOES THE RIGHT
THING REMOVES LEAD FROM HER HOME
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THE THREAT OF A FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUIT FROM A DEEP POCKETED
PAINT COMPANY.
AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT AS MANY
HOMEOWNERS AS POSSIBLE
PARTICIPATE IN THESE ABATEMENT
PROGRAM TO GET LET OUT OF THEIR
HOMES.
OUR BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE MORE
HOMEOWNERS TO PARTICIPATE HELP
IMPLEMENT THE COURT'S DECISION
EFFECTIVELY AND MAXIMIZE THE USE
OF THE ABATEMENT PROGRAM.
ARTS WITH THAT HOPEFULLY MY
OUR WITNESSES ARE HERE.
NEW HOGAN HOLD ON AND ESTABLISH
A QUORUM.
STONE HERE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHIU.
THERE.
AND ALSO FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. PRESS.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM YOUR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
FIRST ALLOW YOU KNOW
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ALSO
HERE FOR CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
CALIFORNIA YOU CONSERVATION
VOTERS PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU LAID OUT THE ISSUE IS
LET THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL OF
LEAD. THIS LAWSUIT.
WORKED ITS WAY THROUGH THE
COURTS THE SIX CALIFORNIAS
YOU'RE TALKING IN THE MICROPHONE
NATURE.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME ISN'T
THAT BETTER CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT DECLINED TO HEAR THE CASE
AND NOW THERE'S A WHOLE SERIES
OF ACTIONS INCLUDING INITIATIVE
THAT HE REFERRED TO WHICH. HAS
ONE LINE IN IT THAT SAYS LED
IT'S NOT A PUBLIC NUISANCE.
I WITH THAT THERE'S THIS PACKAGE
OF BILLS THAT WE SUPPORT ALL OF
THEM. OF THIS IS ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS
ABOUT LIABILITY WE SHOULD HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CHILDREN EXPOSED
AGAIN NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD ZERO
IS WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE IN
CHILDREN. AND THEY EAT PAINT
CHIPS THEY'RE EXPOSED TO DUST
BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
HOUSE LET ALONE FROM EXTERNAL
SOURCES LIKE OLD FREEWAY
DEPOSITION WHEN. FROM A LEADED
GASOLINE SO WHAT PEOPLE DO IN
AROUND THEIR HOUSE WITH LEAD
PAINT IS VERY IMPORTANT WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
BOB NASH CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL RATTING ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NICHOLA DELUCA YOUR BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF EMERYVILLE THE CITY
OF OAKLAND SUPPORT ALL SIX BILLS
IN THE PACKAGE WERE OLD
INDUSTRIAL CITIES REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S DOING AND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TERESA COOK ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
SUPERVISORS HENCE PART.
JACKIE SAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMERATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
EDDIE ON A BRIGHT LINE FENCE
PROJECT AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING FAITH COMING WITH THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ALEXANDER HER NAME
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ART RODRIGUEZ WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EMPOWERMENT ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S KALRA.
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU SHALL I I
WANT TO THANK YOU SENATORS WHO
ALONG WITH OTHER COLLEAGUES WILL
BE HEARING FROM TODAY AT. SOME
OF LIMON CARILLO AND BONTA. OF
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER OF THESE
RELIGIOUSLY IMPORTANT PACKAGE OF
BILLS I THINK THAT. WE
OF THE NEED TO BE SHOWING
LEADERSHIP THAT THE UN OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE SHOWING RIGHT NOW
IN RESPONSE. TO WHAT WE SEE
INDUSTRY DOING AND SALAS WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO VISIT
YOU FOR SETTING THE STAGE FOR US
AS WE WORK OUR WAY THROUGH THE
BILL'S.
THE QUESTION.
OUT SO I MAKE MY COMMENTS NOW
I'M THANKFUL THAT ALL THESE
BILLS ARE COMING FORWARD AND.
MANY OF MY ZIP CODES OF COURSE
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
NUMBER OF. OF YOUNG CHILDREN WHO
TEST POSITIVE FOR LEAD POISONING
UP AND WE'RE NOT SURE.
THE MARRIED OF WASTE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING AT SOME OF
COURSE.
IS THROUGH EXISTING STILL PAINT
ITEM
SOME THROUGH WATER. POSSIBLY
CANDY FROM MEXICO I AM SO
THERE'S A VARIETY OF OF AB
CAUSES BUT WE KNOW IT'S DAMAGING
AND IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO HEAR
FROM OTHER PARENTS THAT I'M NOT
THE ONLY ONE WITH KIDS THAT LIKE
THE WALLS.
SO.
.
SOMETIMES YOU JUST THINK YOU'RE
REALLY BAD PARENTING. MOVE MY
KIDS
ALWAYS LOOKING THOSE WALLS SO
I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE.
SON THOMAS ON THE WINDOWSILL
SENT TO BRING THIS FORWARD
ACTION WHICH. HAS A PARTIAL
RESPONSE I HAVE SOME LEGAL
DOCUMENTS.
AT MY DESK AND IT'S VERY COMMON
FOR CHILDREN TO LOOK WALLS AND
AND CHIU ONE PAGE AND EAT PAINT
CHIPS. ARE IN FACT IT WAS IT
BECAME OUT IN THE LAWSUIT JUST
HOW COMMON THIS IS.
WHICH HAS LED TO AT THIS POINT
ONE OUT OF FORTY CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA WHO SHOW UP LEVELS OF
LEAD PAINT POISONING AND OUR
STATE AND YOUR CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IT WAS WAS PART OF THE LAWSUIT.
THERE.
I TO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE.
ONE OF THE BILLS THAT I.
HAVE INTRODUCED IT'S NOT PART OF
THE PACKAGES ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO TEST OUR CHILDREN ARE
NOT BEING TESTED AS THEY SHOULD.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO DO I'M GLAD
YOU'RE DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU WHEN I KNOW THEIR
NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
INTRODUCED BILLS AROUND LED MORE
BROADLY THAN LEAD PAINT. YOU
HAVE ONE I THINK MISTER KALRA
HAS ONE ANOTHER SO APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
YOU KNOW THEIR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
TO MAKE LOVE VERY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION THANK
IT WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
MOTION IS DO PATHS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHU AYE CHIU AYE
CONSOLES FLETCHER.
CONSOLES WATCHER I HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY I
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RAYOS. REYES I THINK YOU
COLLEAGUES THAT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU MISLIM OWNED PART OF NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAD
AS YOU'VE HEARD THERE IS A
PACKAGE OF BILLS RELATED TO. ADD
LED HAVE AS A FORMER AND LET
PREVENTION SPECIALIST FOR SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND FOR ME AS
WELL. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE
WOULD REMOVE A SIGNIFICANT
HURDLE TO HOLD TO HOLDING PAINT
MANUFACTURES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
HARM CAUSED BY THEIR PRODUCTION
OF LEAD BASED PAINT. EXPOSURE TO
LEAD AS YOU HEARD AND SERIOUSLY
HARM THE CHILD HEALTH EVEN A
SLIGHT AT YOU ELEVATION IN BLOOD
LEVELS CAN REDUCE AYE Q. AND
SENT DEVELOPMENT.
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN'S ARE BEING
EXPOSED TO LEAD IN THEIR HOMES
THROUGH AGING LEAD BASED PAINT
INCREASING THEIR RISK FOR DAMAGE
TO THE BRAIN AND NERVOUS SYSTEM
SLOWED GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
LEARNING AND BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS
HEARING AND SPEECH PROBLEMS. IN
TWO THOUSAND A COMPLAINT WAS
FILED IN ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST THREE MAJOR
PAINT MANUFACTURERS THAT FOUND
THAT FORMER LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROMOTING LEAD PAINT.
A FOR USE IN HOME DESPITE
KNOWING THEIR KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
PRODUCT WAS HIGHLY TOXIC.
AB TWENTY OH THREE WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE AFFECTED BY LEAD
BASED PAINT TO ARE ABLE TO
RECOVER ABATEMENT COSTS FROM LET
ME PAINT MANUFACTURERS IF
NECESSARY. BASED ON THE
JUDGMENTS OF THE COURT THIS
SEEMS TO BE A REASONABLE
APPROACH WITH ME TODAY IS BELLA
TEAM AND THE TS HEALTH OFFICER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF SOLANO COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DIVISION. AND
JENNY LAM A DEPUTY QUE AT COUNTY
COUNCIL PERCENT OCCUR COUNTY TO
SPEAK AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING I'M DOCTOR BELLOMONT
CASH AYE ON THE.
HEALTH OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR SOLANO COUNTY
COME YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN DEALING WITH HOW TO LEAD
POISONING FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
AND AND AND I MUST OFFER THAT
I'M I'M REALLY REALLY PLEASED TO
SEE THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE IN THIS
WAYS TO SOMETHING THAT. THAT I
THINK SPEAKS VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
THE ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE'S I'M
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN OF THE
STATE.
AT AS YOU KNOW LEAD IS
DANGEROUS IN ITS TOXIC EXPOSURE
TO LET US HARMFUL REALLY TO
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES BUT IT IS
ESPECIALLY HARMFUL TO YOUNG
CHILDREN WHOSE BRAINS ARE STILL
DEVELOPING. AT HIGH LEVELS IN
THE BLOOD CAN CAUSE SEIZURES
COMA AND DEATH HAD MODERATELY
BLOOD LEVELS IT CAN DAMAGE THE
NEUROLOGIC SYSTEM THE KIDNEYS
THE CARDIOVASCULAR SYSTEM IN
MULTIPLE OTHER ORGANS. BUT WE
ALSO KNOW TODAY THAT EVEN AT THE
LOW PAY THAT EVEN AT THE LOWEST
LEVELS OF DETECTION IN THE
BLOOD.
BLOOD LEAD CAN IMPAIR LEARNING
MEMORY JUDGMENT IN THINKING IT
RESULTS IN LOWERED IQ IN
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND
DIFFICULTY WITH PROBLEM SOLVING.
AND ATTENTION DISORDERS THEIR
RESULTS IN GREATER STRUGGLES IN
FAILURE DURING A CHILD'S PRIMARY
EDUCATION IT RESULTS IN HIGHER
HIGH SCHOOL FAILURE RATES.
IN A REDUCED SUCCESS IN BOTH
ENTERING AND SUCCEEDING IN
COLLEGE. AND IN LIFELONG
IMPAIRED ECONOMIC SUCCESS IN
PRODUCTIVITY.
IT IS IN ADDITION VERY CLEARLY
AN ISSUE OF INEQUITY AS WELL
AFFECTING PRIMARILY CHILDREN IN
POOR COMMUNITIES.
WE BECOME A WE WE HAVE BEEN
AWARE FOR SOMETIME THAT THERE IS
NO SAFE LEVEL OF EXPOSURE TO LET
FOR CHILDREN. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE DAMAGE DONE TO A
CHILD'S BRAIN IS PERMANENT THERE
IS NO TREATMENT FOR THE DAMAGE
CAUSED BY LET.
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE EXPOSED TO
MANY SOURCES INCLUDING
CONTAMINATED CULTURAL REMEDIES
AND TREATMENTS CERTAIN
CONTAMINATED CONSUMER PRODUCTS
SOMETIMES TOYS. AND WHILE THESE
EXPOSURES COMES ON THE HIGH
LEVELS THEY ARE TYPICALLY VERY
UNCOMMON.
AND AND AFFECT RELATIVELY FEW
CHILDREN BY FAR THE MOST COMMON
SOURCE OF EXPOSURE.
IS THE VERY WIDESPREAD SOURCE
OF OF EXPOSURE TO LEAD IN
HOUSEHOLD PAINT.
FROM THE HOUSEHOLD PAINFUL TO
PICK IT BECOMES INCORPORATED
INTO HOUSEHOLD DUST ESPECIALLY
IN AND AROUND WINDOWS AND DOORS
AS WELL AS INTO THE SOIL AROUND
THE HOME. AND THESE EXPOSURES
SOURCES ARE PERSISTENT SINCE THE
LAND ITSELF DOES NOT
DETERIORATE.
CHILDREN BECOME EXPOSED
EFFECTIVELY THROUGH DOING
NOTHING MORE THAN GROWING UP IT
THROUGH THROUGH THEIR NORMAL
GROWTH BEHAVIORS LIKE CRAWLING
AND HOBBLING THEY COME INTO
CONTACT WITH THE DUST AND THE
PAINT DIRECTLY. AND THROUGH
PLAYING IN THEIR HOMES AND IN
THEIR YARDS THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
LET.
ARE IN SOLANO COUNTY WITH A
POPULATION OF ABOUT FOUR NINE
THIRTY THOUSAND AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOMES WE HAVE OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES THAT WERE BUILT
BEFORE NINETEEN FIFTY. AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND FOUR NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT SO THE ISSUE FOR
US IS VERY VERY WIDESPREAD.
A STRONG SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY THE
AUTHOR AND BECAUSE THIS BILL
HELPS FAMILIES TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE PREVENTION OF
HAZARDS POSED BY LEAD. AS WELL
AS MITIGATION OF THOSE HAZARDS
CAUSED BY THE TO PAINT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ANGER.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH THREE ALTHOUGH THE BILL
LARGELY COULD IF I ITS LEGAL
PRINCIPLES ARTICULATED BY THE
COURT OF APPEAL IN THE. VAN MARK
LEAD PAINT CASE BROUGHT BY THE
SENATE CLARA COUNTY COUNSEL'S
OFFICE ALONG WITH NINE OTHER
CITY COUNTY. CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS
AND IT ENSURE THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THESE IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES
ARE NOT RIVERS BY FUTURE COURTS
AND IT ALLOWS PLAINTIFFS TO MORE
EASILY ESTABLISH THESE ELEMENTS
IN FUTURE PUBLIC NUISANCE CASES.
THE ONE AREA IN WHICH AB TWENTY
EIGHT OF THREE DEPARTS FROM THE
COURT'S DECISION IN OUR CASES
WITH RESPECT TO CONSTRUCTIVE
KNOWLEDGE. AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
THREE HOLDS THE LEAD INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT IT SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THE HEALTH
HAZARDS CAUSED BY THEIR PRODUCT.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY APPROPRIATE
IN THIS CASE WHERE THAT HAS BEEN
KNOWN TO BE TOXIC SINCE WELL
BEFORE THE TURN OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE LEAD
INDUSTRY WHAT WAS WELL WHERE FOR
DECADES THAT THIS PRODUCT
BECAUSE LED PETE IS LEAD
POISONING IN YOUNG CHILDREN AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
YOUNG AND. YOUNG CHILDREN AS
WELL AS POOR AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AND THEY CONTINUE TO
SELL THEIR PRODUCT FOR DECADES
AFTERWARDS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE
RECOGNIZES THE COMPANY XIN
ESCAPE. RESPONSIBILITY BY
BURYING THEIR HEADS IN THE SAND
ABOUT THE THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
BEING POISONED BY LEAD PAINT.
THE CONTRACT OF KNOWLEDGE
STANDARD IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
GENERAL TORT LAW PRINCIPLES
UNDER BOTH NEGLIGENCE AND STRICT
LIABILITY CAUSES OF ACTION
LIABILITY CAN BE ESTABLISHED
WITH CHEST PROOF OF. OF
CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE AND UNDER
NUISANCE LAWS WELL LIABILITY CAN
BE ESTABLISHED THROUGH
CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE SO THIS
BILL IS ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING TOWARD LINE WE URGE
THAT YOU SUPPORTED AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE FILL OUT
WE DON'T ENVIRONMENT WORKING
GROUP THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS DELUDE GET THE CITIES
OF OAKLAND AND NEVER AND
EMERYVILLE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PAID CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
ATTY ON A BRIGHT LINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
Q. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION
.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST ON CAP HE WITH MCCUE CAP
CAN'T ASSOCIATES HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
A. WHILE THE APPLICATION OF
PUBLIC NUISANCE LAWS TO HOMES
WITH INTERIOR LEAD BASED PAINT
IS CONCERNING WITHOUT QUESTION
THE EXPANSION OF THAT SONG LEGAL
THEORY AND THE PRECEDENT THAT
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WOULD SET.
IS EVEN MORE CONCERNING A
PROBLEMATIC FROM A MANUFACTURING
STANDPOINT.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
UNDERLYING CASE WAS SOLELY
LIMITED TIME TO INTERIOR LEAD
BASED PAINT. AND EXCLUDED
EXTERIOR LEAD BASED PAINT OTHER
REASON THE COURTS DID THIS OUT
WAS THAT THERE WAS INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE PROVIDED. THAT
ESTABLISHED HARM RELATIVE TO THE
EXTERIOR BASED LEAD PAINT. AND
THERE COULD BE OTHER
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS ASSOCIATED
WITH A LEAD IN THE EXTERIOR
ENVIRONMENT.
WE'RE CONCERNED WITH REGARDS AB
TWENTY EIGHT OVER THREE BECAUSE
A GREATLY EXPANDS LIABILITY FOR
PAINT MANUFACTURERS RETAILERS
DISTRIBUTORS WHETHER THE PAIN
WAS USED INTERNALLY EXTERNALLY
OR WHETHER THERE IS ACTUAL HARM
ASSOCIATED AND DETERMINED TO BE
THE. RESULT OF THAT LEAD BASED
PAINT IN THE HOME.
THE LIT THE BILL IS APPLICABLE
TO ALL HOMES FURTHER BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THE UNDERLYING
LITIGATION INSTEAD OF THOSE PRE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE AS
ESTABLISHED IN THE UNDERLYING
LITIGATION IT EXPANDS THE RISK
FAR BEYOND THAT. AND THE BASIS
FOR THE LIABILITY AGAINST THESE
MANUFACTURERS EVEN THOUGH THE
COURT DETERMINED THAT THE PUBLIC
NUISANCE LAW SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO THAT TIME PERIOD. BASED ON
THE FEDERAL BAN OF LEAD BASED
PAINT AND THE KNOWLEDGE OF BY
HOMEOWNERS OF HEALTH HAZARDS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
THE BILL OF A CRIME FURTHER AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE ARMED IT
ITS EXPANSION OF PUBLIC NUISANCE
LIABILITY COULD ALSO FROM A
MANUFACTURING STANDPOINT HAVE A
PROFOUND EFFECT ON THE BUSINESS.
CLIMATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND.
COULD SET UP CONCERNING
PRECEDENT FROM A STANDPOINT OF
MANUFACTURERS.
AND DOWN THEIR PRODUCTS OUT
BEYOND EVEN LEAD BASED PAINT IN
THE FUTURE. THAT WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT TWENTY YOU
KNOW THREE COULD HAVE ON THE
HOMEOWNERS THEMSELVES AS WELL.
BY DO YOU MEAN THEIR HOMES
PUBLIC NUISANCES AS WELL AS THE
LOSS OF VALUE ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AS WELL. FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US.
MORNING I MY NAME IS HEIDI
MCAULIFFE FROM WITH THE AMERICAN
COATINGS ASSOCIATION. ACA
REPRESENTS OVER NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE COATINGS
MANUFACTURES THE UNITED STATES
AND IN CALIFORNIA. ARM WE ARE
THE PAIN INDUSTRY EMPLOYS OVER
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
THEY RECEIVE AVERAGE WAGES OF
ABOUT FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON THE PAYROLL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE.
THE BREADTH OF THE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MANUFACTURES
ITSELF PAIN INTO THE STATE. AND
FOR THE SAKE OF CLARITY I DO
WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
ACA'S MEMBERSHIP.
.
WHILE SHARON WILLIAMS COMPANY IS
A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
COATINGS ASSOCIATION. AND I'LL
INDUSTRIES AND CONAGRA OR NOT
SHERMAN WILLIAMS IS A PAINT
MANUFACTURER.
CONAGRA AND NL INDUSTRIES DO NOT
MAKE PAINS AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
AS WELL ACA IS NOT A LITIGANT IN
THE. COURT OF APPEAL AND THE
CALIFORNIA VERSUS CONAGRA
LAWSUIT NACA HAS NO INVOLVEMENT
AT ALL WITH THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE THE HEALTHY HOMES AND
SCHOOLS ACT.
BECAUSE THE THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE IS NOT A PAIN
INDUSTRY EFFORT IT ISN'T EFFORT
ON BEHALF OF THOSE THREE
COMPANIES.
THE DECISION AND CALIFORNIA
VERSUS CONAGRA IS WRONG OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE WHICH
PROVIDES FOR EVEN EXPANDED
LIABILITY BEYOND THAT. IS
INAPPROPRIATE IN DEPRIVED
MANUFACTURERS OF BASIC FAIRNESS.
ACA AND THE CALIFORNIA PAIN
COUNCIL CANNOT.
RESPECTFULLY DO NOT SUPPORT
TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE IS THIS
BILL IMPOSES LIABILITY ON
PARTIES.
THAT PROMOTED LEAD BASED PAINT
WITHOUT ANY DIRECT LINK BETWEEN
THE PRODUCT AT ISSUE IN THE
PERSON MAKING THE CLAIM WE
DISAGREE WITH THE COURT OF
APPEALS DECISION FOR THIS VERY
SAME REASON.
THE DIRECT LINK BETWEEN THE
CONSUMERS HARM IN THE PRODUCT
THE BECAUSE THE HARM IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS OF
DUE PROCESS AND OF LIBERTY AND
PROPERTY FOR ALL.
IN LAYMAN'S TERMS DUE PROCESS
MEANS THE FAIR TREATMENT IN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
OR PREVENTING ARBITRARY DENIAL
OF LIFE LIBERTY OR PROPERTY BY
GOVERNMENT OUTSIDE THE SANCTIONS
THE LAW. ALL INDUSTRIES NOT JUST
THE PAIN INDUSTRY DEPEND UPON
DUE PROCESS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
FAIRNESS AND SETTLEMENT OF
DISPUTES.
TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE IS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO REMOVE
THOSE STANDARDS AND PROCEDURES
THAT DEMAND FAIRNESS.
OF THE ANALYSIS CLEARLY STATES
THIS IN SEVERAL PLACES AB TWENTY
EIGHT OF THREE PROVIDES FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED PRODUCTS
LIABILITY. MUCH FARTHER THAN
THAT ENVISIONED BY THE COURT OF
APPEALS DECISION BY INCLUDING
EXTERIOR PAINT.
A CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE NOT
ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE AND NO RELIANCE
ON THE ALLEGE PROMOTION.
A AND IT'S UNCLEAR AS TO WHETHER
THE ACT OF PROMOTION INCLUDES
THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
SPECIFICATIONS THAT REQUIRED THE
USE OF LEAD BASED PAINT AND
BUILDING. AND MAINTENANCE
SPECIFICATIONS OVER THE YEARS.
THE ANALYSIS ALSO STATES THAT
LEAD BASED PAINT ALWAYS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE UNSAFE IN THE
FUTURE IF IT DETERIORATES. BUT
ISN'T THIS TRUE OF ALMOST EVERY
PRODUCT IN YOUR HOME.
IF ALLOWED TO DETERIORATE
CARPETING THAT ISN'T TACK DOWN
TO LEAD TO FALLS IN BROKEN HIPS
NATURAL GAS HEATING THAT LEAKS
RESULTS IN CARBON MONOXIDE
POISONING AND DEATH.
MEMBER DO YOU NEED TO DROP OUT.
.
JUST ONE LAST COMMENT THAT
THERE'S BEEN DECADES OF WORK BY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROFESSIONALS.
BY EPA THE DEPARTMENT OF HUD IN
THE US CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OF THREE
COMPLETELY UNDERMINES THIS WORK
OVER RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
CONFUSION. AND SEEMINGLY ENDLESS
LITIGATION. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
ADAM LIKELY ON BEHALF THE CAL
CHAMBER A JUST REAL QUICK WERE
OPPOSED BECAUSE THE BILL
ACTUALLY GOES BEYOND THE CASE
THAT'S WHY WE'RE OPPOSE.
ANYONE ELSE IT UP.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
THE ONE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I THINK
THAT DUE PROCESS QUESTIONS
ULTIMATELY GET RESOLVE SINCE
THEIR HEALTH WE STATE SUPREME
COURT DECIDED NOT TO TAKE UP THE
CASE THEY WERE SATISFIED WITH
THE DUE PROCESS ISSUES AND.
THAT THE CASE WAS THE COURTS
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS LIABILITY BUT
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT WE ARE ASSIGNING LIABILITY
IS AS WE SEE FIT WHERE IN FACT
NOT BOUND BY THE COURTS AND
THERE PRECEDENTS WERE CERTAINLY
INSTRUCTED BY THEM. SO FOR US
TO.
EXPAND ON WHAT THE COURT TODAY
AND ESPECIALLY WHERE WE FIND A
PRODUCT TO BE QUITE SO DANGEROUS
SAYS.
AS LEAD PAINT IS THAT SWELLED
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE.
LEGISLATURE TO DO SO YOU CAN BE
OPPOSE FOR THAT STEP BUT THE
FACT THAT WE'RE GOING BEYOND THE
COURT IS WELL WITHIN OUR PURVIEW
AND SOME.
THIS LEGISLATURE DOES ALL THE
TIME
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR ALL OF US TO.
UNDERTAKE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION THAT IT'S THE
THREE COMPANIES BRING IN THE THE
BALLOT MEASURE NOT NECESSARILY
ENTIRE. PAINT INDUSTRY.
BUT IT'S ALSO SEEMS TO ME VERY
CYNICAL.
ATTEMPTS TO GET OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH A LIABILITY AND AND
SHIFT.
TO THE PUBLIC THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR HAVING CREATED SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT HARM. AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS I THINK THAT A
NUMBER OF THE
SPILLS.
I'VE BEEN SPAWNED.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER KALRA
I'M GONNA SAY DETERMINES SHELVES
IN A SAKE NOT QUITE SO
ELOQUENTLY WHAT YOU SAID BUT
ESSENTIALLY HEARD THE COMMENTS
YOU MADE AND THAT IS WHAT ALSO
SEND IT TO A. SEGMENT OF LIMON I
HAD IT'S INTERESTING WHEN YOU
WANT ME TO GET HEARINGS IN AND
GET TO HEAR COMMENT FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AND YOU LEARN A LOT
ABOUT THEIR BACKGROUND AND SAID
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE.
EXPERIENCE IN AND THAT
MITIGATION AND AND HARM
REDUCTION I THINK UP IS IS GREAT
FOR ALL OF US.
CERTAINLY FOR YOU TO BRING THAT
EXPERTISE.
AS A COLLEAGUE AND I THINK AS
PART OF THE TEAM THAT'S BRING
THE PACKETS WERE NOTHING THAT'S
THE TIMING IS GOOD IN TERMS OF
THE BODY SO. I PER SHAPING THE
BILL FOR IT.
BUT TO.
THANK MISTER CHAIR I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
AND YOUR SUPPORTERS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND AND A
A CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
THAT.
THAT THERE'S.
THEIR NOT SUPPORTIVE OF TRYING
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
.
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE'S
INITIATIVE THAT COULD COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE THE LIABILITY THESE
THREE COMPANIES.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING WHY THE
AUTHOR FEELS LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR WITH THIS AND.
AND I WOULD SIMPLY ASK THE
OPPOSITION IF THE INITIATIVE
PASSES.
OF WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE US DO.
JOINT HAPPY FOR C. MTA I
APOLOGIZE I'M NOT PREPARED TO
SPEAK TO THE INITIATIVE SEEMED
HAY.
IT WOULD BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU OFFLINE SO I THINK I
THINK THAT'S THE CHALLENGE AND
AND WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE THREE
COMPANIES BUT THEY'RE NOT HERE
TODAY. UMP THEY'VE SENT YOU.
TO REALLY REPRESENT THEIR
PERSPECTIVE.
SO THIS IS WHY I THINK WE HAVE
WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THIS ENTAILS NOW IF I
UNDERSTAND.
YOUR ONLY REPRESENTING ONE OF
THE THREE COMPANIES BUT YOU'RE
NOT ASSOCIATE YOURSELF WITH THE
INITIATIVE AT THIS TIME RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT. THAT QUESTIONS
DIRECTED ME THAT'S CORRECT WE
REPRESENT SHERMAN WHIMS AS A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN COATINGS
ASSOCIATION BUT WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OTHER MEMBERS AS
WELL OKAY AND AND MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT IS.
YOU BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE
ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO TO PROVE WHAT HAS BEEN
AN INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT THING TO
PROVE IS THAT RIGHT.
JOHN KEPT YOU FOR CMT I THINK
THAT'S ONE PIECE OF IT AS WELL
AS EXPANDED MY ABILITY TO
PERHAPS I EVEN COMPANIES. AYE
THAT PERHAPS ARE NOT PARTY TO
THE LITIGATION NOT INVOLVED WITH
LEAD BASED PAINT AS WELL SO I
THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT. AYE COUPLE OF ISSUES
AND I IN ADDITION TO THAT.
IF I COULD JUST SUBSEQUENT I'M
SORRY YOU WITH THE AMERICA IT
HIDING MCAULIFFE AMERICAN
COATINGS ESOS OKAY* US A
QUESTION WHEN YOU WERE TWO YEARS
OLD.
DO YOU KNOW.
.
WHERE THE PAINT ON THE WALLS OF
THE HOUSE ELEVEN WAS FROM?
IT'S NOT A QUESTION I CAN ANSWER
I I DON'T THINK SO DO YOU KNOW
WHO THE MANUFACTURER WAS OF THE
PAINT.
AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION I CAN
ANSWER.
REPUBLICAN FIND THE RECEIPTS TO
PROVE WHERE YOU BOUGHT THAT
PAINT RIGHT.
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT IS WHY WE
ARE HERE.
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR YOU HAVE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WHO
HAVE LEAD POISONING.
YOU ADD THAT UP FOR DECADES.
BILLIONS UPON BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN WHO
EXPERIENCE LEAD POISONING HAVE
FOUGHT THIS INDUSTRY FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND YOU ARE SHIELDING THREE
COMPANIES.
THAT WANT TO BUY THEIR WAY.
OUT OF PAIN FOR THEIR LIABILITY.
IF YOU HAVE A BETTER ANSWERS ON
WHAT WE CAN DO WE'RE ALL EARS
BUT THIS IS OUR BEST ATTEMPT TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WOMEN FOR
THIS BILL.
I THINK THAT AS A MOTION AND A
SECOND BY MISTER KALRA.
IF YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SING THEM.
IS THE ONE YOU MAY CLOSE I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT.
AT THE WHAT'S BEEN SAID THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S
IMPORTANT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT HAS
EXISTED I'M IN OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTIES WORKAROUND LET
PREVENTION HAS HAPPENED FOR
DECADES. ON INCOME AND COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS REALLY
A RESPONSE I TO THE FACT THAT
HOMEOWNERS MAY BE ON THE LINE
FOR THIS AND I THINK THE COURTS
HAVE MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ON THE LINE.
AND AND.
THE INITIATIVE WOULD REVERSE
THAT AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
PART OF OUR RESPONSE AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN CODIFY. THE
COURTS AYE DECISION IN THIS AND
THAT WE ENSURE THAT I ANY
LIABILITY AND IT DOESN'T PHAM
THE HOME OF CALIFORNIA DOES UPON
THE FAULT OF THAT OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND INSURERS THAT
ON THOSE WHO HAD KNOWLEDGE ON
THAT THIS WAS INDEED A TOXIC
MATERIALS AND HAD ADAM OUT
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. AYE
ARE RESPONSIBLE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE BUT.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION THAT WE HAVE IS DO
YOU PATH KALRA PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHOW. CHOW
I CHIU BY CHIU AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN.
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. WAS CARILLO.
OUR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B. TO
NINE NINE FIVE.
WELCOME.
WELL GOOD GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PERCENT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE. A MEASURE THAT EMPOWERS
HOMEOWNERS TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AND THEIR CHILDREN FROM THE
DEBILITATING EFFECTS OF LATE
LEAD PAINT IN THEIR HOMES.
WHICH YOU'VE HEARD. ON FOR. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE ON THE BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
CERTAIN PAINT MANUFACTURERS
KNOWINGLY SOLD LEAD PAINT THAT
WAS USED IN HOMES ACROSS THE
STATE FOR DECADES.
AND WITH THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF GENERATIONS OF
FAMILIES.
ON TOP OF THAT THE PERVASIVENESS
OF LEAD PAINT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. REVEALED
THE DISTURBING PRACTICE WARPING
COMPANIES CONTINUOUSLY HAVE PUT
PROFITS OVER PEOPLE AND OVER THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS HEALTH.
IN RESPONSE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST IT CALLS OUT THE PRESENCE
OF LEAD PAINT FOR WHAT IT IS.
A POISON THAT IS A DAMAGE TO
PROPERTY AND A HEALTH HAZARD.
THE MERE PRESENCE OF LEAD PAINT
IN OUR WALLS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN BECAUSE ANY DISTURBANCE
CAN FLAKE LET US INTO THE AIR.
AND WE AND OUR CHILDREN WILL BE
THAT.
THIS MUST BE DEALT WITH
EVENTUALLY AND EVERY HOME.
ESPECIALLY AS PROPERTIES BUILT
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ARE REMODELED OR DEMOLISHED
AND THAT CANNOT BE DONE WITHOUT
DISTURBING THE LEAD PAINT
UNDERNEATH ARE ON THE SURFACE OF
THE WALTZ.
THIS IS A GREAT HEALTH RISKS TO
ALL OCCUPANTS.
SECOND THE BILLS THAT THE CLEAR
AND FAIR STANDARD FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO TAKE ACTION.
THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF STARTING
THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS TO
PURSUE LEGAL ACTION AFTER
SIGNING A VAGUE DISCLOSURE FORM
IS UNREASONABLE.
THE PRESUMPTION THAT LEADS.
THE PRESUMPTION THAT LED IT
FIFTH CONCERN HOMES AS A FLIMSY
COP OUT THAT SEVERELY LIMITS THE
TIME FRAME FROM HOMEOWNERS TO
TAKE ACTION. AND IS NOT ACTUALLY
BASED ON FACT OR KNOWLEDGE OF
WHETHER THE LEAD ACTUALLY EXIST.
TO RIGHT THIS WRONG AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY FIVE SETS THE
STARTING POINT FOR TAKING ACTION
TO WIN A HOMEOWNER HAS ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE OF LEAD PAINT. IN
THEIR HOME.
AT THAT MOMENT OF DISCOVERY
PROPERTY OWNERS WOULD HAVE THE
MUCH DESERVED TIME AND ABILITY
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION THE CDC. STATE
THAT THERE IS NO LEVEL THERE IS
NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD IN
CHILDREN'S BLOOD. ANY AMOUNT
NO MATTER HOW TRACE IS TOXIC.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE INJURIES ARE
FELT ALL ACROSS OUR STATE FROM
EUREKA TO SAN DIEGO. IN LOS
ANGELES THE CDC FOUND
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE FIVE PERCENT
OF CHILDREN HAVE ELEVATED LEAD
LEVELS.
IN SOME AREAS OF FRESNO THIRTEEN
POINT SIX PERCENT OF CHILDREN
TESTED HAVE ELEVATED LEAD LEVELS
THAT'S NEARLY THREE TIMES THE
RATE FOUND IN FLINT. MICHIGAN.
DURING THE CITY'S WATER
CONTAMINATION CRISIS WHICH
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
THE GRAVITY OF THIS ISSUE
DEMANDS ACTION AND THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE HOMEOWNERS HAVE THE
LEGAL POWER TO PROTECT THAT
SAFETY NOT ONLY FOR THEIR HARD
EARNED PROPERTIES BUT MOST
CRITICALLY.
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND LOVED
ONES
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS JENNY
LAM SANTA CLARA COUNTY COUNCIL
AND BELLA MATE THAT'S A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND.
SORRY HEALTH OFFICER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF SOLANO COUNTY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD MORNING CAN. THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA IS ALSO PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE.
UNDER EXISTING TORT LAW
NEGLIGENCE AND STRICT LIABILITY
CAUSES OF ACTION ALREADY EXISTS
TO HOLD CULPABLE PARTIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR INJURY TO
PROPERTY THIS BILL SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES WHAT WE ALL ALREADY
INTUITIVELY KNOW. THAT LEAD
PAINT CONSTITUTES A PHYSICAL
INJURY TO PROPERTY.
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS AGO AT THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY COUNSEL'S
OFFICE FILED ITS LOOK OUT
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE FORMER LEAD
PAINT MANUFACTURERS. AND EARLY
ON IN THAT CASE THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES THAT WERE INVOLVED
INCLUDED CLAIMS FOR NEGLIGENCE
AND STRICT PRODUCTS LIABILITY
BUT THE TRIAL COURT GRANTED THE
DEFENDANT'S MOTION FOR SUMMARY
JUDGMENT ON THE BASIS THAT THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HAD RUN.
ON APPEAL THE COURT OF APPEAL
SUBSEQUENTLY HELD THAT THE
CLAIMS HAD NOT YET A CRUDE
BECAUSE WE HAD FAILED TO PLEAD
THE EXISTENCE OF ANY PHYSICAL
INJURY TO OUR BUILDINGS.
THIS IS BECAUSE UNDER PREVAILING
MUST BE PHYSICAL HARM TO
PROPERTY OR PERSONS AND NOT NEAR
ECONOMIC LOSS.
THIS EXISTING AT CASE LAW IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY FIVE IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS
TO SUE FOR DAMAGES TO REMEDIATE
THEIR PROPERTIES BUT BEFORE
FAMILIES ARE EXPOSED TO
DETERIORATE LATE. DETERIORATED
LEAD PAINT AND BEFORE THE
ATTENDANT HEALTH HAZARDS ACCRUED
TO THEIR FAMILIES.
AND BY EXTENDING THE TIME IN
WHICH PLAINTIFFS MAY BRING
ACCLAIM AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE PROVIDES A REASONABLE TIME
FRAME FOR LEAD POISONED
INDIVIDUALS TO BRING CLAIMS ONCE
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE KEY INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
MAKE SUCH A CLAIM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US BUT.
GOOD MORNING DOT BRAILLE MY CASH
HEALTH OFFICER AND DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR SOLANO COUNTY.
I'M EVERDAY AND TESTIFIED ON THE
HARMS OF LEAD BUT I GET ONE AT A
COUPLE OF OTHER POINTS WITH
RESPECT TO LEAD THAT I THINK ARE
GERMANE FOR THIS BILL. IN SOLANO
COUNTY AGAIN AT A MEDIUM SIZE
COUNTY WE HAD AN AVERAGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE CHILDREN PER YEAR
OVER THE LAST THREE FOUR YEARS
REPORTED WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS AND WE HAD A HUNDRED
CHILDREN REPORTED AS RECENTLY AS
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AGO.
GIVEN THE LOAD RIGHTS OF
CHILDREN WHICH WAS LOADED TO
VOTE BY ONE OF YOUR MEMBERS OF
THE TRUE NUMBERS OF CHILDREN IN
MY COUNTY WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEVELS IS CONSIDERABLY HIGHER.
AND THESE NUMBERS ARE NOT
DIMINISHING
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'D BEEN OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
REPORTED ANNUALLY WITH ELEVATED
BLOOD LEAD LEVELS OF THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS AGAIN THESE
NUMBERS ARE NOT DIMINISHING. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THESE CHILDREN IN
THESE FAMILIES WHO ARE NEW TO
THESE HOMES ARE LIVING IN HOMES
THAT WERE PAINTED WITH WITH
LEADED PAINT FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
THEY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF THE
HAZARDS THAT THEY'RE MOVING INTO
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE ECONOMIC
MEANS TO ADDRESS THOSE OR TO
MOVE OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
AND SO THE EXPOSURES ARE
PERSISTENT IN THEIR ON GOING IN
THE VERY VERY WIDESPREAD.
GIVEN THE DAMAGE COSTS
CHILDREN'S BRAINS IS PERMANENT
AND THAT THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL
OF EXPOSURE TO LOOK FOR CHILD
THE ONLY REASONABLE COURSE OF
ACTION IS PREVENTION. AND WHEN
IT WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH LET
IT HOUSEHOLD PAINT PREVENTION
MEANS ABATEMENT THROUGH ITS
COMPLETE REMOVAL ARE COMPLETE
CONTAINMENT.
SO IN ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS IRREVERSIBLE
ADVERSE EFFECTS OF LEAD
POISONING ON DEFENSES CHILDREN
THAT ARE COMPLETELY AVOIDABLE.
SO STRONG SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE. THAT BUT AGAIN FOR
THE REASONS CITED BY THE AUTHOR
AND BECAUSE THIS BILL HELPS TO
MUCH BETTER CLARIFY THE HAZARDS
THAT ARE POSED BY LEADED PAINT
AND IT ENABLES FAMILIES TO
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE THE
PREVENTION THOSE HAZARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
OKAY ON A BRIGHT LINE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IT CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
SO WE OUR JACKETS WITH CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT.
BILL ELLIOTT ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARDS SUPERVISOR
SUPPORT.
WE GO TO LOOK AT THE CITIES OF
OAKLAND IN EMERYVILLE IN
SUPPORT.
GEN A PRICE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IT'S PART.
ART RODRIGUEZ WITH CENTRAL
IMPAIRMENT ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
I DON'T KNOW SINCE SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER
BROWN TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS OP PROPOSAL. OUR
CONCERN IS WITH REGARDS TO THE.
MANDATE THAT BASICALLY ANY
PRESENCE OF LEAD PAINT AND A
RESIDENTS IS.
A DAMAGE TO THE PROPERTY AFTER
EIGHTEEN OR SO YEARS OF
LITIGATION THE COURT WAS
EXQUISITE.
IN THE UNDERLYING CASE THAT
ONLY INTERIOR LEAD PAINT CREATED
A HAZARD.
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T FIND
EVIDENCE OF EXTERIOR PAINT
CREATING THAT SAME TYPE OF
HAZARD AND SO OUR CONCERN AT
THIS THIS IS BROAD ENOUGH TO
CAPTURE BOTH INTERIOR AND
EXTERIOR PAINT DESPITE THE
FINDINGS BY THE COURT AFTER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF LITIGATION.
THAT THAT DIDN'T CREATE HAZARDS
WE HAVE CONCERNS FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO
LIMITING THIS.
WITH REGARDS TO ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE INSTEAD OF THE NORMAL
PREMISE OF TORT LIABILITY THAT
INCLUDES CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE.
AND.
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
IMPACT THAT THAT WOULD HAVE THE
DISCLOSURE IT ISSUE AS WELL
THAT'S REYES WHERE IT GIVES
NOTICE THAT THIS COULD INCLUDE
LEAD PAINT.
AND NOT NOT CREATE AN ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE IS ALSO CONCERNED.
IF THAT DISCLOSURE IS
MEANINGLESS THEN EXIT SIMPLY WHY
DO WE HAVE IT.
IF IT DOESN'T CREATE KNOWLEDGE
AND SO WE ALSO HAVE A CONCERN
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE AND
FINALLY WITH REGARDS TO DAMAGES.
ON THE UNDERLYING CASE I'D DEALT
WITH ABATEMENT PUBLIC NUISANCE
ABATEMENT IT'S SAID THAT
SHARON'S THAT ANY OF THE LEAD
PAINT IN THOSE HOMES THAT ARE
DESIGNATED WILL BE UTILIZED TO
REMEDIATE. THE POTENTIAL HAZARD
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH DAMAGES
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE THAT THE
DAMAGES WILL BE UTILIZED TO
ABATE THE HAZARD SO WE HAVE
CONCERNS FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE
AS WELL FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
POST.
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN DORY ABOUT
THE CIVIL DISASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
I WANT TO START BY MAKING. SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT ARE THE
BASIS OF OUR OPPOSITION ISN'T
ABOUT THE CLEAR DANGER OF LEAD
AND LEAD PAINT.
WHICH WHILE ONCE WAS CONSIDERED
AN INDUSTRY STANDARD AND IS IN
FACT PROMOTED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ITS PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS.
A IT WE'VE NOW LEARNED THAT
IT'S CLEAR ON AND DANGEROUS
HEALTH EFFECTS ARE.
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED SO THE ISSUE
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
PACKAGE OF BILLS TOGETHER MANY
OF WHICH WE ARE NOT OPPOSING
BECAUSE WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF. OF.
REMEDIATING.
LEAD PAINT WHERE APPROPRIATE ON
THE ISSUE FOR US IS THAT WHEN
YOU LISTEN TO THE PROPONENTS AND
YOU READ THE ANALYSIS IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS IS A SIMPLE EXTENSION.
OF EXISTING CASE LAW BECAUSE THE
FACT THAT DEFENDANTS AND EXACTLY
PROVING WHO IS.
RESPONSIBLE FOR DAMAGES IS NOT
NEW ON IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
MANY YEARS AND THE COURTS HAVE
DEVELOPED A NUMBER OF THEORIES
FOR DEALING WITH THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AT THAT THE
CASES OF BOTH DAMAGE AND
LIABILITY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
COMES UP IS A SIN DEL VERSUS
ABBOTT LABS CASE. THAT WAS THE
CASE FROM WHERE WE FIRST STARTED
LOOKING AT.
BOTH MARKET SHARE AND RISK
CONTRIBUTION THEORIES.
THAT CASE INVOLVED ON THE DRUG
DE YES WHICH WAS.
PROVEN TO CAUSE CANCER EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS PRESCRIBED TO
PROVE IT TO LIMIT.
AND MISCARRIAGES ON AND IN THAT
CASE.
THE COURT FOUND THAT THE
DEFENDANTS ON MARKETED WHEN THEY
KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN IT WAS
A CARCINOGENIC SUBSTANCE AND
THEY WEREN'T VIOLATIVE. OF.
FDA WARNING REQUIREMENTS
ON ANOTHER CASE IT'S FREQUENTLY
CITED IS THOMAS SOURCES MALLET
WHICH IS WISCONSIN STATES
PURPOSE SUPREME COURT. IN THAT
CASE THE COURT HELD THAT THE
ORDER TO APPLY IN ORDER APPLY
RISK CONTRIBUTION THEORY THE
PLAINTIFF WOULD BE CARD SHOW
THAT THAT THE LAD THIS IS A LEAD
PAINT. PAINT CASE THE LEAD WAS
INGESTED
THE LEAD BECAUSE THE INJURIES
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS PRODUCE
THE TYPE OF LOVE INGESTED. AND
THAT THE DEFENDANT'S CONDUCT.
BREACHED A DUTY AND SO WHERE
WORK CONCERN HERE IS THAT IN
THESE CASES WHERE RIGHTFULLY THE
COURT HAS FOUND THAT IT'S HARD
TO PICK.
REGULAR DEFENDANT WHO'S AT FAULT
ON THEY THEY CONTINUALLY APPLY
ON TWO TESTS ONE IS WAS THERE
HARM AND TO WAS THERE NEGLIGENCE
OR BREACH OF DUTY.
AT THIS AS A BILL COUPLED WITH
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR ELIMINATE
BOTH OF THOSE
ON THAT'S ARE CONCERNED IT'S A
BIG EXPANSION OF LIABILITY ON UP
FOR A JUST CAUSE BUT THE WRONG
APPROACH NOW FOR THOSE.
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY PUPS.
THANK YOU ANYWHERE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I MCAULIFFE AMERICAN COATINGS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU.
DRAW COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION THEN WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GOODNESS CARILLO I THANK YOU
FOR.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THEN AND
AGAIN I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
CONCERNS AND WHEN THAT. WITH THE
COURTS LOOKING AT AT ITS
PRECEDENT THAT.
IS AWAY FOR TO DEFINE MY ABILITY
BUT OF COURSE WE ARE NOT SO BAD
LOANS WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
LIABILITY QUESTIONS ESPECIALLY
AROUND RISK THAT IS THE JOB OF
LEGISLATURE.
SHE IS WHY IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION FOR YOU TO ASK FOR US.
WHICH YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIR AND.
I USUALLY OPPOSITION STAYS FOR
QUESTIONS BUT.
I'LL JUST ASK MY QUESTIONS OUT
TO THE PUBLIC.
A GREAT WHERE YOU'RE COMING
BACK.
SO.
.
QUESTION ARE YOUR ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTING INITIATIVE.
NO.
TAKING A POSITION
HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON
THAT QUESTION ARM. SO A ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT IS RAISED BY THE
PROPOSED BILL.
IS AROUND ACTUAL HARM AND UP I
JUST LIKE TO QUOTE AS WAS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS. UP
FORMER CHIEF JUSTICE.
RONALD GEORGE OF FORMER
REPUBLICAN CHIEF JUSTICE RONALD
GEORGE ON THIS VERY ISSUE.
AND WHAT HE SAID WAS WHY SHOULD
A HOMEOWNER HAVE TO WAIT FOR
PERSONAL INJURY TO RECOVER
DAMAGES ISN'T PER FORMAL TO PAY.
A RELATIVELY FEW DOLLARS AT AN
EARLY DATE TO CORRECT ASSUME
VIEW A SERIOUS SAFETY RISK
RATHER THAN WAIT FOR DISASTER TO
STRIKE IN FOR DEATH OR PERSONAL
INJURY TO ASSURE. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING OF YOUR POSITION
IS THAT.
YOU BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACTUAL INJURY DEFINED AS
CHILDREN WHO EXPERIENCE LEAD
POISONING WHO'VE EXPERIENCED.
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISKS.
FOR ONE CAN MAKE THE CASE THAT
THIS NEEDS TO BE ABATED IS THAT
YOUR POSITION NOW THAT WAS MY
POSITION OKAY WILL.
THIS BILL IS DEALING WITH
DETERMINING THAT LEAD PAINT ON
ANY RESIDENTIAL.
AREA OF ANY PRESIDENTIAL IS.
DEEMED AT A PROPERTY INJURY AND
OUR CONCERN WAS THAT IT THE
COURT NARROWED AFTER EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF LITIGATION TO DO
INTERIOR PAINT BECAUSE THAT IS
WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE EXPOSED
TO IT. AS YOU INDICATED YOUR SON
WITH REGARDS THE WINDOWSILL AND
THE WALLS.
IF IT CHIPS OR FLAKES THE COULD
INGEST IT WHEN THEY'RE AROUND ON
THE ON THE FLOOR.
THIS IT DOESN'T LIMIT IT TO
INTERIOR PAINT WHERE THEY'VE
SEEN THE HEALTH HAZARD AND IT
THE EXTERIOR PAINT THEY I DIDN'T
FIND ENOUGH EVIDENCE AFTER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF LITIGATION TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT WOULD BE A
HEALTH HAZARD.
AND THAT WOULD DEEM IT UP
INJURY TO THE PROPERTY BECAUSE
THERE IS TOO MANY EXTERIOR BY
MENTAL ISSUES AND CONDITIONS
THAT COULD CONTRIBUTE. ONTO THE.
ISSUE OF LEAD WITH REGARDS TO
OUTSIDE THE HOME OUTSIDE THE
INTERIOR AND SO THAT WAS OUR
POSITION IS THIS BILL DOES NOT
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN INTERIOR AND
EXTERIOR FOR PURPOSES OF
DETERMINING WHEN AND IT'S A
ENTRY TO THE PROPERTY. GENETIC
WHAT I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES.
THATCH ONE THAT WAS EXPERIENCED
DURING THE EIGHTEEN LAWSUIT WAS
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO PROVE.
EXACTLY WHAT HARM CHILDREN WHO
ARE INSIDE OR OUTSIDE THE HOUSE
HOW THEIR AND JUST TO LET A
WHICH IS EXACTLY MY
UNDERSTANDING WHY THE AUTHOR
WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE
IT.
A LITTLE BIT EASIER FOR UP FOR
TO BE PROVEN BECAUSE WE KNOW
COMMON SENSE TELLS US THAT
CHILDREN WERE PLAYING RIGHT
OUTSIDE HOUSES. ARE JUST AS WHEN
THEY'RE ON THE INSIDE OF THE
HOUSE MIGHT BE JUST AND LEAD THE
ON THE OUTS ON THE OUTSIDE THE
HOUSE MIGHT BE DOING THE SAME SO
I THOUGHT I THINK WE WOULD
MAYBE HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON THAT BUT BUCKLEY
DISAGREED BUT YES BUT YOU'RE NOT
DISPUTING.
THE PORTION THIS BILL HAVING TO
DO WITH ACTUAL HARM IS WHAT I
ACTUALLY THOUGHT I'D HEARD FROM.
FROM YOU SO SO THAT ASPECT OF
THE BILL YOU'RE FINE WITH NO WE
ARE JUST DISCUSSING BETWEEN TORT
LIABILITY FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
I'M SORRY AND SUBJECT PLEASE.
REVIEWED DON'T WANNA AND
DOMINATE BUT OF THE ISSUE WITH
REGARD TO CONSTRUCT KNOWLEDGE
VERSUS ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE AND WHEN
THAT DISCLOSURE THAT YOU'RE IN A
PRE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HOME
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY CLEAN.
HAVE LEAD PAINT AND IT WHETHER
OR NOT THAT'S ENOUGH TO PUT YOU
ON NOTICE I'M THAT YOU NEED TO
INVESTIGATING CHOIR AS NORMAL
TIGHTLIPPED TORT LIABILITY
REQUIRES A BIT OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
YET I THINK THAT THE ISSUE ABOUT
HARM IS REALLY ABOUT HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT KIDS ARE NOT
EXPOSED TO LEAD PAINT. ON A
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR DEBORAH
TEASES THE ONE WHO CARRIED THE
BILL THAT SAID IF YOU ACTUALLY
REMEDIATE AND COVER ENCAPSULATE
THE LEAD. SO THAT IT IS NOT A
RISK.
THAT IS HOW YOU.
UP PREVENTED SO I THINK THAT
THE QUESTION IS ON WANTS TO.
TRY TO PUT FORTH A BILL THAT
SAYS AUTOMATICALLY THE PRESENCE
OF ANY LEAD IN A IN A.
AND ANY ONE DROP OF LEAD IN THE
HOUSE IS A HEALTH HAZARD IS AN
ISSUE WHEN THERE'S LEAD IN THE
SOIL THERE'S LET YOUR
STRAWBERRIES THERE'S LEAD. ON IN
YOUR TOYS ON THAT THAT'S WHERE
WE GET ON A TO OUR DISAGREEMENTS
ARE IT'S NOT ABOUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT YOU SHOULD
WAIT TO HAVE KIDS. EXPOSED TO
LEAD POISONING IT'S ABOUT THERE
ARE MANY WAYS TO.
TRY AND MITIGATE THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF LEAD AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT STATUTORILY MAKING
IT. ANY OUNCE OF LEAD ANYWHERE
IN THE HOUSE AS A THE OFFICIAL
DAMAGE THAT CAN BE SUED OVER. IS
THIS IS THE RIGHT REMEDY.
SO AGAIN A AND I'LL ASK A
QUESTION THAT I ASKED BEFORE.
.
SO. I HANDFUL LEAD PAINT
COMPANIES MADE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SELLING
PAINT WITH LEAD IN IT THAT THEY
KNEW WERE GONNA HARM CHILDREN.
AND ENTIRE GENERATIONS OF
CHILDREN WERE HARMED AND UNDER
YOUR LEGAL THEORY THEY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO BE HELD LIABLE.
I DISAGREE WITH THAT GUIDE THE
COURT UNDER THE EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF LITIGATION THERE'S A BILLION
DOLLAR ABATEMENT FUND AGAINST
THOSE THREE COMPANIES UNDER THE
THEORY PUBLIC NUISANCE TO
OVERRIDE OUR ELIMINATE THE
HEALTH HAZARDS. ASSOCIATED WITH
INTERIOR INTERIOR PAINT USING
RESIDENTIAL HOMES WHICH ALL OF
THE DATA AND JOURNAL AND ALL OF
THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED IN THAT
CASE FOCUSED ON IT AND DIGITAL
CRIBS TOYS. ALMOND WINDOWSILLS
AS BEING THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
LEAD EXPOSURE FOR CHILDREN STONE
IN HIS POINT YOU'RE SUPPORTING
THAT COURT CASE.
I'M NOT SUPPORTING THE QUIRKY
SOME JUST YOUR YOUR COMMENT AS
IF I APPRECIATED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WAS THAT WE'RE SUGGEST NATION TO
BE HELD LIABLE AND I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT AT ALL I'M JUST
SUGGESTING THAT. THIS GOES
BEYOND THAT TO INCLUDE EXTERIOR
RESIDENTIAL PAINT AND LIMITS BE
CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE THAT IS
UTILIZED IN NORMAL TORT
LIABILITY SO OUR CHALLENGE
THOUGH IS.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO THINK THE
COURT CASE OUGHT TO STAND WE
HAVE A BALLOT INITIATIVE THAT'S
ABOUT TO NEGATE IT.
SO WHAT'S YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN.
MY PERSPECTIVE IS WELL A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
I'M NOT.
WEHAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION ON
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE BUT I AM
FAMILIAR WITH IT AND.
IT PROPOSES FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING PLEASE CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG BUT PROPOSES A BOND
IN WHICH TO.
ELIMINATE.
HEALTH HAZARDS INCLUDING LEAD
PAINT AND IT SUGGESTS THAT A LED
PENA HOME IS NOT A PUBLIC
NUISANCE IF THE VOTERS APPROVED
THAT THAT'S AN INDICATION OF THE
VOTERS THAT THEY DON'T AGREE
WITH THE COURT CASE IN THAT THEY
DON'T AGREE. THAT THEY SHOULD
MOVE FOUR DOES A PUBLIC NUISANCE
SO I DON'T I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT THE VOTERS
APPROVE OF THAT THEORY OR NOT
AND THEN COME BACK AND DEAL WITH
IT FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE. IT
COULD BE THAT THE VOTERS MAY BE.
DECEIVED ABOUT WHAT THIS
MEASURES ABOUT THE FACT THAT IT
IS ALLOWING THREE TOXIC PAINT
COMPANIES TO ESCAPE THEIR
BILLION ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR LIABILITY. WITH ONE LINE
IN THAT INITIATIVE THAT
ELIMINATES WHAT IT TOOK EIGHTEEN
YEARS IN THE COURT TO.
OVERCOME YEAH I DON'T I BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT DEPENDS I
GUESS ON HOW THE CAMPAIGN I'M
DEVELOPS OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
VOTERS UNDERSTAND UNIT I MEAN
WHAT'S BEING DISCUSSED IN THAT
INITIATIVE SO THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST IT'S. DETERMINAR
ON THE WILL OF THE VOTERS THINK
ABOUT MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AND JUST TO PUT ON THE
RECORD A GOOD EXAMPLE OF I THINK
WHAT WE'RE HEADED FOR.
MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED THE
NUMBER OF LETTERS FROM
CONSTITUENTS.
THAT WERE ALARMED AT THIS NOTION
OF THE. THE SHIFT AND AND THE
CREATION OF A OF A PUBLIC
NUISANCE.
SO WE DUTIFULLY GOT BACK TO THEM
TO FIND OUT.
WHAT THEY'RE CONCERNED REALLY
WAS BECAUSE THEY WERE OUTRAGED
AT THE COURT DECISION ACCORDING
TO THE LETTER AND YET IN EVERY
SINGLE CASE? WHAT THEY TELL US
IS WE WANT TO A WEBSITE?
TO FIND INFORMATION.
THEY DID NOT SEND THE LETTER
THEY HAD NO INTENTION OF SENDING
A LETTER.
SO THIS IS WHY MISTER CHIU
BRINGS UP THIS NOTION OF
DECEPTION.
ONE WHAT WE'RE FACING IS A.
VERY CYNICAL POTENTIALLY WELL
CLEARLY DECEPTIVE SITUATION
BEING FOISTED UPON THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOING TO SHIFT
THE PAIN COMES LIABILITY
ACCORDING TO THE COURT CASE.
TO THE PUBLIC
AND IF THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
AND THE AND THE COURTS ARE GOING
TO MAKE FOR THAT THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO.
BUY THAT LINE AND MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION THEN THE SETS OF BILLS
ARE IN FACT CHANGING THE
CALCULATION OF LIABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT WE STILL CAN HOLD
THOSE WHO ARE HAVE CAUSED TO
HARM KNOWINGLY CAUSE THE HARM.
ACCOUNTABLE THAT'S THAT'S THE.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SINGGAH IN THIS CAREER
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU CLEARLY BE THE
CONVERSATION AT HAND SHOWS US.
THAT THERE IS MUCH TO BE DONE.
WHEN THE WITH REGARDS TO LET
PAIN AND HOMES I BELIEVE THAT.
PROTECTING THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS ABOUT
PROTECTING THE HARD WORKING
FAMILIES THAT WANT THE DREAM TO
BE A REALITY. AND WANT THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR CHILDREN TO
BE SAFE THE AMERICAN DREAM IS
NOT ABOUT PROTECTING THE
CORPORATIONS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE NOT LIABLE FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF KNOWINGLY SELLING.
LEAD PAINT THAT HAS HOT HAD.
INCREDIBLE.
.
ISSUES ON HEALTH WHICH CHILDREN
AND WITH FAMILIES ACROSS OUR
STATE
THIS IS ABOUT THE VALUES OF OUR
STATE THIS IS ABOUT HOW WE
PROTECT FAMILIES THAT WE PROTECT
CHILDREN. AND HOW WE ENSURE THAT
WE ARE HOLDING CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE DAMAGE THAT
THEY HAVE DONE. AND SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OF SILICON FOR MOTION
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SECOND
AMENDED.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY HIS
ARREST IN THE SECOND BY MISTER
TO.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHU AYE CHIU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
SO I SEE MISTER BONTA HERE.
WE HAVE MISSED BUT YOU HAVE TO
BILLS WE'RE DOING THAT THE LEAD
BILLS TOGETHER.
WE'VE TAKEN THESE AS AS A BLOC
AT WHICH IS A LITTLE.
OUT OF ORDINARY BUT I SAW MISTER
LEVINE HERE SO WHAT I'M WHEN
ASKED ABOUT HIS IF YOU PRESENT
YOUR LEAD PAINT BILL THAT WE CAN
LET MISTER LEVINE GO SINCE HE'S
BEEN VERY PATIENT. AND THAT AND
THEN DO YOUR SECOND BELL IF YOU
DO THAT THEN I THINK WE. TRY TO
RESPECT THE FOLKS WHO WERE OR
ATTEMPTED DECIDED TO MANAGE
THEIR WAY THROUGH OUR COMMITTEE.
SO WE'LL TAKE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWO OH SEVEN FOR.
AND THAT WILL.
EMPLEADO FOR LESS PAY BILLS OF
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT MORNING STAFF
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR
TODAY I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THAT PAIN AND. THIS
DIFFERENT POLICY APPROACHES
TO ALLOW FOR THOSE THAT HURT BY
LEAD PAINT TO ACHIEVE JUSTICE.
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL CENTER
FOR DISEASE CONTROL PREVENTION
LEAD PAINT IS THE LEADING CAUSE
OF CHILDHOOD. LEAD POISONING AND
TOO MANY OF OUR CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN PERMANENTLY HARMED. BY
EXPOSURE. TO LEAD THE CDC THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AND
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ALL AGREE THAT THERE
IS NO. KNOWN LEVEL OF LEAD
THAT'S SAFE ANY AMOUNT OF LEAD
HURTS OUR CHILDREN.
FOR TOO LONG PIC COMPANIES HAVE
AVOIDED RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PRODUCING SELLING.
ST DISTRIBUTING LEAD BASED PAINT
INNOCENT VICTIMS OF LEAD
POISONING FACE LONG ODDS IN
TRYING TO SEEK JUSTICE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE CLEARLY
HARMED BY A LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURER CURRENTLY EVEN WHEN
IT IS CLEAR.
THAT MOST WOMEN YOU FACTORS
PROVIDED AN DISTRIBUTED WEBSITE
PRODUCED AND DISTRIBUTED THE
PAINT THAT CAUSED THE INJURY
VICTIMS MUST PROVE THE EXACT
MANUFACTURER. WHOSE LEAD PAINT
THEY INGESTED BUT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF TIME THE LOSS OF
RECORDS. THAT.
THE PAINT COMPANIES OFTEN
CONTROL AND THE NUMBER OF
MANUFACTURERS IT IS VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO OVERCOME.
THIS BURDEN OF PROOF LEAVING
TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF INNOCENT POISONED CHILDREN
WITHOUT COMPENSATION.
FOR THEIR INJURIES
AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR WILL HELP
CHILDREN AND PARENTS
STEVE JUSTICE FOR THE PERMANENT
DAMAGE INFLICTED ON THEM.
AND WILL HELP THEM RECEIVE THE
CARE SPECIAL SERVICES THEY NEED
AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR WILL
CREATE A MORE FAIR. LEGAL
PATHWAY FOR ANYONE HURT BY LEAD
PAINT.
IT JUST THIS BY ADOPTING WHAT'S
KNOWN AS A RISK CONTRIBUTION AND
IT'S RELATED TO OTHER
SIMILAR THEORIES IN THE LAW. AND
IN THE MASS TORT CONTEXT THIS
MODEL ALLOWS THE PLAINTIFF TO
MAKE INITIAL SHOWING. OF HARM
AND CAUSATION AND SHIFT THE
BURDEN TO LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS TO SHOW THAT THEY
WERE NOT.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INJURY.
THIS IS NOT ONLY FAIR BUT THE
LEAST WE CAN DO. FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
WITH ME HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
ISABEL ALLEY ARE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP I
HAVE ALSO HAVE GINNI LAMP DEBBIE
CAN'T COUNTY COUNCIL FOR THE
COUNTY SANTA CLARA. AND OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SHOULD BE
NEEDED I HAVE AYE JAMIE HULING
DELAY DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY OF
THE SENSES CHO CITY ATTORNEYS.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD MORNING TONY LAM CAN FROM
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA WHICH
IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FOR THIS BILL BUILDS ON
THE FACTS ESTABLISHED IN THE
LAWSUIT THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
MORNING.
AND IT'S ALREADY WELL
ESTABLISHED THE EGREGIOUS
CONDUCT THAT THE LEAD INDUSTRY
ENGAGED IN AS WELL IS THE
HARDEST TO CHILDREN. AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FOUR HELPS TO ADDRESS
THAT. THAT COSTS HAD TO THE
VICTIMS OF LEAD POISONING BY
ALLOWING THEM TO MORE EASILY
ESTABLISH AT THAT THAT.
PRODUCER SELLERS TO SHOOTERS AND
PROMOTERS BECAUSE THEIR INJURIES
AND THEREFORE TRUCK TEEN DAMAGES
FOR THEIR INJURIES AS WITH
ALTERNATIVE MARKET SHARE
LIABILITY. AND ALTERNATIVE
LIABILITY THEORIES GENERALLY AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR RECOGNIZES
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE INNOCENT
VICTIMS WHO THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. HAVE DIFFICULTY
IDENTIFYING THE SPECIFIC ENTITY
THAT BECAUSE THERE HARM. AND
WHEN YOU HAVE DEFENDANTS WHO
UNQUESTIONABLY ENGAGED IN
TORTIOUS CONDUCT THAT IT IS
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE TO SHIP
PART OF THE BURDEN OF PROOF TO
THE DEFENDANT'S.
A.
AB AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR. ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT VIS A VIS
INDIVIDUAL PLAINTIFFS THE LEAD
INDUSTRY IS IN A SUPERIOR
POSITION TO KNOW AND PRODUCE
EVIDENCE ABOUT WHERE THEY
MANUFACTURED DISTRIBUTED SOLD
AND PROMOTED THEIR PRODUCTS.
THEY ARE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
ABSORB THE COSTS OF THE LEAD
POISONING THAT THE CHILDREN HAVE
SUFFERED AND THEY CAN AND HAVE
INSURE THEMSELVES AGAINST
LIABILITY FOR THEIR PRODUCTS.
BUT AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR DOES
NOT ELIMINATE THE CAUSATION
REQUIREMENT IN THESE CASES IT
STILL REQUIRES A PLAINTIFF TO
PROVE THE EXISTENCE OF THE
PRESENCE OF A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
LEAD PAINT PIGMENT AT A
PARTICULAR EXPOSURE LOCATION. IT
STILL REQUIRES A PART OF
PLAINTIFFS TO PROVE THE
EXISTENCE OF ESTABLISH SPECIFIC
PATHWAY BY WHICH LEAD PAINT
PIGMENT WITH ACTUALLY
INTERESTED.
AND IT STILL REQUIRES A
PLAINTIFF TO PROVE THE CAUSAL
LINK BETWEEN THE INJECTION OF A
LEVEL LEAD PAINT PIGMENT ANTS
THE ASSERTED ENTRY. AND A
DEFENDANT CAN STILL PROVE THAT
IT DID NOT PRODUCE SELL
DISTRIBUTE OR PROMOTE THAT LEAD
PAINT PIGMENT IN THE RELEVANT
GEOGRAPHIC MARKET OR TIME
PERIOD.
SO NOW AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR
DOES NOT ESTABLISH A SLAM DUNK
CASE OF ABSOLUTE LIABILITY.
IN FACT THE FIRST AND ONLY CASE
TO GO TO TRIAL UNDER THE RISK
CONTRIBUTION THEORY IN WISCONSIN
FOUND THAT THE PLAINTIFF FAILED
TO PROVE THAT HIS INJURY WAS
ACTUALLY CAUSED BY THE INGESTION
OF LEAD PAINT.
NO IT IS AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR
MAKE EVERY INDIVIDUAL
MANUFACTURE THE INSURER OF EVERY
OTHER MANUFACTURER.
WHAT IT DOES DO IS TO ALLOW
PLAINTIFFS TO ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THEIR CASES
IN COURT AND TO SEEK REDRESS FOR
THE CREATURES HOMES THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE TO THEM BY THE LEAD
INDUSTRY?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
ALLOW LEO ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE HAZARDS OF LEAD BOTH
IN THIS BILL PACKAGE IN OTHER
BILLS IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND THE
SENATE.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT THE KIDS
NOT ONLY LICK WALLS THEY EAT
DIRT. AND THEY GET LEAD PAINT
CHIPS IN THEM THAT WAY THAT OF
LOVE UPON BY THE SIDE OF THE
HOUSE SO.
THERE'S MULTIPLE AVENUES OUT WE
THINK THIS BILL ISN'T
SCAPEGOATING ANY PARTICULAR
MANUFACTURING WHEN IT IS MORE
FAIRLY ALLOCATING THE LIABILITY.
AS THE.
REPRESENTED FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY STATED OF SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CENTRALIZES RIGHT RODRIGUEZ OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EMPOWERMENT
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE.
GOOD MORNING LIANE TREND FOR
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NICCOLO DELUDE OF THE CITIES OF
OAKLAND IN EMERYVILLE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ATTY ON A BRIGHT LINE IS ALSO
WORTH MENTIONING BRIGHT LINES
COMMUNITY PARTNERS CAN YOU
CENTER A PHILIP RANDOLPH
INSTITUTE OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN AND WE HAVE
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
ECONOMY THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WANT TO PLACE IN THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR.
THANK YOU WILL KNOW WHAT OTHER
SUPPORTER FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OPPOSITION PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER BRAGGING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE OPPOSED AB TWENTY SEVENTY
FOUR. I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
AND.
HEARING THE PACKAGE OF
DISCUSSION OF BILLS ABOUT
WANTING TO HOLD MANUFACTURERS OF
LEAD PAINT.
COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EXPOSURE AND THE HAZARD AND
HEALTH RISK THAT THE OF COSTS
THEIR CHILDREN BUT THIS BILL
GOES WAY BEYOND THAT.
IT TOUCHES ANY COMPANY WHO AS
ANY PART IN THE STREAM OF
COMMERCE WITH REGARDS TO LEAD
PIGMENT NOT LEAD BASED PAY LEAD
BASED PAINT. NOT LEAD BASED
PAINT THAT IS UTILIZED IN
INTERIOR HOMES OR EVEN AT HOMES
AT ALL IT GOES AFTER EVERY
COMPANY IN THAT STREAM CONGRESS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAD.
KNOWLEDGE OF ANY HEALTH HAZARDS
WHETHER OR NOTTHEY ACTUALLY.
PROMOTED MARKETED OR
DISTRIBUTED LED PIGMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PURPOSES OF LEAD
BASED PAINT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ACTUALLY CAUSED THE INJURY.
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY HEALTH
HAZARDS.
ASSOCIATED WITH A CHILD OR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WITH REGARDS TO
EXPOSURE TO LEAD BASED PAINT WE
HAVE A HUGE CONCERN OF THE FACT
THAT IT UNDERMINES THE WHOLE
EXISTENCE OF TORT LIABILITY AND
HOLDING IN THE COMPANY. UP
RESPONSIBLE
A PRODUCT THAT THEY HAVE CREATED
AND THE INJURIES THAT THAT
PRODUCT HAS COST
AND IF WE CAN GO THROUGH I CAN
TOUCH ON HOW WE READ THE BILL
AND HOW WE READ HOW BROAD THE
EXPOSURE IS UP FOR LIABILITY IN
THIS BILL.
IT'S BEYOND THE RISK MAP A
LIABILITY DOCTRINE THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED IN THE ANALYSIS IT'S
BEYOND MARKET SHARE LIABILITY
THAT'S DISCUSSED IN THE ANALYSIS
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY. AYE
REFERENCE TO ANY PROPOSAL OF
SUCH EXTREME TORT LIABILITY AS
PROPOSED IN AB TWENTY SEVENTY
FOUR SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST
PROVISION OF THE BILL. IT SAYS
THAT ANY DISTRIBUTOR
MANUFACTURER OR ANYBODY WHO
PROMOTED THE TYPE OF LEAD
PIGMENT THAT CAUSE THE INJURY
THAT'S THE BURDEN OF PROOF THAT
THE PLANE PASSED TO ESTABLISH.
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO CALIFORNIA
SO UNDER THE PROPOSAL A BILL IT
DOESN'T SPECIFY THAT YOU HAD TO
HAVE IT MANUFACTURED SOLD
DISTRIBUTED OR PROMOTED BY
PIGMENT IN CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO SATISFY THEIR BURDEN
WHICH WAS ONE OF THE KEY
ROVISIONS ARE KEY ISSUES IN THE
UNDERLYING LITIGATION.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO IF YOU DON'T
HAVE TO SHOW THAT IT WAS THE
ACTUAL LEAD PAINT PIGMENT.
THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED
MANUFACTURED OR PROMOTED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAUSED THE
INJURY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY SHOW
THAT YOU MANUFACTURED
DISTRIBUTED OR PROMOTED LED
PIGMENT FOR PURPOSES AB IN LEAD
BASED PAINT INSIDE A HOME.
THERE'S ACTUALLY LED PIGMENT WAS
UTILIZED FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REASONS CERAMICS
OPINION ON SHIPS OPINION ON
BRIDGES THERE IS NO INDICATION
THAT ALL LEAD PIGMENT WAS
UTILIZED IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PURPOSE OF LEAD BASED PAINT ON
HOMES. SO WE HAVE A HUGE CONCERN
THAT SOMEBODY CAN BE HELD LIABLE
UNDER THIS THEORY OF LIABILITY
EVEN THOUGH THEY NEVER PRODUCE
THE PRODUCT THAT IS AT ISSUE
WITH REGARDS TO EXPOSURE TO
CHILDREN AND THE HEALTH HAZARDS
IT'S CREATED. THERE AND AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THE LITIGATION FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS THAT CASE WAS
LITIGATED COMPANIES WERE
DISMISSED
BECAUSE THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
AGAIN THEY NEVER DISTRIBUTED
PROMOTED OR MARKETED LED PIGMENT
FOR PURPOSES OF LEAD PAINT A
RESIDENTIAL HOMES AND SO THE
COURT DISMISSED THEM. BOTH
COMPANIES UNDER THE THEORY OF
LIABILITY WOULD NOW BE BROUGHT
BACK IN.
ONCE THE PLAINTIFF ESTABLISHES
THAT BURDEN OF PROOF WHICH WE%
SEE AS AS SOMEWHAT LIMITED.
THE BURDEN IS NOW ON THE
DEFENDANT TO PROVE A NEGATIVE.
THEY HAVE TO PROVE THAT THEY DID
IT
DISTRIBUTE MANUFACTURER PROMOTE.
LED PIGMENTS AND DURING THE
RELEVANT TIME PERIOD OR THE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA NEITHER ONE OF
THOSE RACES OF WHICH ARE
DIFFERENT.
PROVING A NEGATIVE IS ABOUT
CHALLENGING I WOULD SAY IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE I WILL UTILIZE ONE OF
THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
COMPANIES INVOLVED IN THIS WHO
HAVE SAID. WE.
A COMPANY THAT I WILL SAY IT
WAS NOT AYE INVOLVED IN THE
UNDERLYING LITIGATION BUT AS
SAID WE OFTEN A KEEP RECORDS OF
THINGS THAT WE DO DO WE DON'T
KEEP RECORDS OF THINGS THAT WE
DON'T DO AND SO PROVING A
NEGATIVE IS A HUGE CHALLENGE.
BUT LET'S GO EVEN BUT BEYOND
THAT. UNDER THIS BILL AGAIN GET
LET'S TALK ABOUT A COMPANY THAT
DISTRIBUTED LED PIGMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CERAMICS
SO THAT SATISFIED THEIR BURDEN
OF PROOF AND THEN IT GOES ON TO
THEIR AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE. THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SHOW
NECESSARILY BUT THEY DIDN'T
DISTRIBUTE OR MARKET LED PIGMENT
IN CALIFORNIA. AND A CERTAIN
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA DURING THE
RELEVANT TIME PERIOD EVEN THOUGH
THEY COULD SHOW IT WAS NEVER
UTILIZED FOR THAT THE PACE IT
WOULD STILL BE LIABLE. FOR ALL
INJURIES ASSOCIATED WITH LEAD
PICNIC CALIFORNIA HUNDRED
PERCENT MY ABILITY AND THAT'S
WHERE THE MARKET CHAIR LIABILITY
IN THE RISK BY A BILL THE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THIS IS
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY.
MEANING IF YOU ARE EVEN ONE
PERCENT ON THE HOOK YOU ARE A
HUNDRED PERCENT LIABLE FOR ALL
INJURIES IT'S NOT ASSOCIATED
IT'S NOT ALLOCATED AMONGST THE
DIFFERENT COMPANIES. WHO
MANUFACTURED THE LIMPING IT'S A
ALLOCATED TO YOU ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT ON THE HOOK AND THESE
ARE INDEED ENTITIES I WANT TO
SAY? OTHER WERE BROUGHT UP IN
THE UNDERLYING LITIGATION WHO
AGAIN HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
CREATING THE PRODUCT LA TIMES LA
TIMES PROMOTED THE USE OF LEAD
BASED PAINT. BACK WHEN IT WAS
UTILIZED IN THE STATE AND I
THOUGHT THAT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
HEALTH REASONS OAKLAND TRIBUNE
THEY OFFER UP PROMOTED MARKETED
LEAD BASED PAINT AS WELL SO BE
IT UNDER THIS PROPOSAL. WILL BE
A HUNDRED PERCENT ON THE HOOK
FOR THAT.
HARM CREATED IN THESE HOMES FOR
LEAD BASED PAINT EVEN THOUGH
THEY NEVER CREATED A PRODUCT SO
AGAIN OUR CONCERN IS THIS GOES
WELL BEYOND JUST HOLDING THE
COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE THAT
CREATED LEAD BASED PAINT FOR
INTERIOR USE OR EVEN ON THE
RESIDENTIAL USE. AND HOLDS
ANYBODY LIABLE IN THE STREAM OF
COMMERCE EVEN THOUGH THEY WANT
TO CREATE THE PRODUCT IT DIDN'T
CAUSE ME HARM DIDN'T HAVE
ANYTHING ASSOCIATED WITH LEAD
BASED PAINT FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
MISTER MEMBERS SAID JOHN DORY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
AFICIONADOS VISION I WOULD JUST
ADD TO.
MISS BARROWS ELOQUENT THAT
TESTIMONY OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD
BE LIABLE UNDER THIS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
PROMOTING AND WE'RE RECOMMENDING
LEAD PAINT.
DURING A TIME WHEN PEOPLE WERE.
IMPRESSED BY ITS ABILITIES TO
HELP SPREAD OUT TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF A CONTAGIOUS DISEASES.
ON I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
ISSUES ON THAT THAT WE ARE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE WAY THAT
LIABILITY WORKS I'VE HEARD A LOT
OF COMMENTS.
ABOUT HOW ON PINK COMPANIES ON
THAT KNOWINGLY A DISTRIBUTED
DANGEROUS PRODUCTS ARE TRYING TO
ESCAPE THEIR.
RESPONSIBILITIES HERE AND THAT
IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THEIR THEIR THEORIES OF
LIABILITY UNDER WHICH YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW GO AFTER THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS IF THAT IS TRUE AND
IN FACT THE ONE OF THE. THE
GROUND BREAKING CASES ARE A TALK
ABOUT INSTANT DEL VERSUS ABBOTT
LABORATORIES IT WAS A DRUG CASE.
BUT IT'S THE EXACT SAME
ALLEGATIONS THAT THERE WAS A
DRUG MANUFACTURERS WHO KNEW THAT
THE PRODUCT WAS DANGEROUS THEY
WERE WORN BY THE FDA ABOUT IT
AND THEY CONTINUE TO MARKET IN
ORDER TO MAKE A PROFIT.
THAT THERE WAS NO NEED TO IN
THAT CASE TO SHOW THAT IT
INDIVIDUAL MANUFACTURER WAS THE
ONE. ON THE OTHER THING THAT WE
NEED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IS THE WAY JOINED SEVERAL
LIABILITY WORKS WHICH IS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY FIND THE
PERSON WHO ENGAGED IN THE TYPE
OF CONDUCT THAT'S BEING ALLEGED
HERE TODAY. YOU JUST NEED TO
FIND ANYBODY WHO WAS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT IF I'M IF I WAS A A
TRUCKING COMPANY AND I WAS
DELIVERING PAINT. ON.
AT FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
MANUFACTURE NOT ONLY MY LIABLE
UNDER THIS BILL I'M LIABLE FOR
ALL OF THE DAMAGE.
I'M SO IF THE IF THE IF THE
CONCERN IS THAT THERE IS AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS ESCAPING
LIABILITY.
FOR.
YOU KNOW CONDUCT THAT IS.
INTENTIONAL OR NEGLIGENT.
YOU WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT BILL
IN FRONT. OF THIS IS THE BILL.
THAT MAKES ANYBODY ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT REGARDLESS OF
WRONGDOING A NEGLIGENT THAT'S
THE WAY JOINED SEVERAL LIABILITY
WORKS IT PUTS ONE DEFENDANT ARM
ON THE HOOK FOR ALL OF THE
DAMAGES AND SO THOSE ARE
CONCERNS.
AND WE WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
A NOVA.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
HEIDI MCAULIFFE AMERICAN
COATINGS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AFTER ALL CUT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
KILEY.
I JUST FOR THE AUTHOR OR ANY OF
THE PROPONENTS I'M.
I'M STRUGGLING UNDERSTAND THE
HOW YOU CAN HAVE.
RISK CONTRIBUTION OUR MARKET
SHARE LIABILITY WHICH IS KIND OF
A NOVEL ENOUGH AYE THEORY IS IT
ISN'T AND COMBINE THAT.
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY HOW
THOSE
EVEN GO TOGETHER IN A COHERENT
THEORY OF LIABILITY Y. HAS
JOINED SEVERAL LIABILITY
APPROPRIATE HERE.
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY IS
NOT A NEW CONCEPT ENDS IN THE
ANALYSIS FOR THE SPELL AND THE
COUNSEL FOR THE COMMITTEE NOTED.
THAT WISCONSIN ALREADY HAS RISK
CONTRIBUTION THEORY APPLIED IN
THAT STATE AND JOINT AND SEVERAL
LIABILITY ALSO APPLIES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH RISK
CONTRIBUTION THERE. AND I WILL
SAY THAT JOINED SEVERAL
LIABILITY DOES NOT MEAN THAT A
SINGLE DEFENDANT SUDDENLY
BECOMES LIABLE FOR THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY. IN OUR LAWSUIT THAT
YOU'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT JOINT
AND SEVERAL LIABILITY ALSO
APPLIED WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEFENDANT'S UNDER AYE PUB PUBLIC
NUISANCE THEORY. AND DEFENDANTS
WERE UNDER EXISTING CASE LAW
DEFENDANTS COULD PRESENT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR SHARE OF
THE LIABILITY IN ORDER TO ALLOW
THE COURT TO APPORTION LIABILITY
AMONG THE DEFENDANTS THEY
PRESENTED NO EVIDENCE THEY CHOSE
NOT TO PRESENT ANY EVIDENCE. IN
ORDER TO APPORTION THE LIABILITY
AMONGST THEMSELVES AND SO THEN
THEY ENDED UP JOINTLY AND
SEVERALLY LIABLE.
I THINK IT IS ANYONE IN THE
OPPOSITION HAVE ANY.
YOU KNOW.
THE COMMENTS ON HOW THEIR
THEORY OF LIABILITY HERE DESERVE
DIFFERS FROM WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST YEAH I THINK THAT THERE'S
TWO THINGS THAT I THINK THAT YOU
MADE A GOOD POINT WHICH IS
PUTTING THEM TOGETHER IS WHAT
THE ISSUE IS. ONE ARM ADD TO THE
POINT AT HAND ON WHEN YOU HAVE
NAMED DEFENDANTS THAT ARE ALL
BEING SUED TOGETHER THAT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. THE
PROBLEM WITH JOINED SEVERAL IS
THERE'S NUMBER OF DEFENDANTS WHO
ARE NOT AT THE TABLE WHO MAY BE
BANKRUPT OUT OF BUSINESS OR NOT
SUIT OR OR FOUND SAID SAID THAT
CONCERN.
JUST.
JUST. APPORTIONED AMONG THE
NAMED DEFENDANTS DOESN'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM THE OTHER THING I'D
SAY TO THE WISCONSIN AND THE
INCIDENT THAT IS TRUE WHAT WAS
SAID. BUT IN FACT THAT THE.
STILL REQUIRES DAMAGES AND A
BREACH OF DUTY WHICH THESE TWO
CASES ELIMINATES WHEN YOU PUT IT
ALL TOGETHER.
IT'S A IT'S A LIABILITY STORE.
IF I JUST MAY FOLLOW UP ON THAT
EVEN FURTHER MY UNDERSTANDING IS
WITH REGARDS THE WISCONSIN CASE
THAT AFTER THAT CASE COME OUT
THE LEGISLATURE THE FOLLOWING
YEAR PASSED LEGISLATION THAT
SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO UTILIZE
MARKET SHARE LIABILITY OR RISK
BY BUILDING A LONGER. AND WITH
REGARDS TO THAT CASE
SPECIFICALLY AGAIN IT WAS THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE ACTUAL
PRODUCT THAT WERE INVOLVED NOT
ANYBODY WHO TOUCHED AN
INSTRUMENT COMMERCE NOT ANYBODY
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED
WITH THE ACTUAL MANUFACTURES THE
PROJECT IN SOMETHING THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP EARLIER BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THE INABILITY FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
TO IDENTIFY WHICH ONE UMPS WOULD
WHOSE PRODUCT WAS ACTUALLY IN
THE HOME AT THE TIME THEY IT
LIMITED TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
SPECIFICALLY.
NOT ANYBODY AGAIN AND THE
STREAM OF COMMERCE AND SO THIS
BILL GOES FAR BEYOND THAT I'M
AND HOLDS ANYBODY WHO'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER CAN THEY ACTUALLY
MADE THE PRODUCT.
IF YOU AND YOUR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE STILL LOOKING FOR A
MOTION THE MOTION WOULD BE TO
PASS A MAKE A MAKE A MOTION AND
AND JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS I
THINK. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT MANY OF US ARE GRAPPLING
WITH IS HAS TO DO WITH THE
QUESTION I ASKED A LITTLE
EARLIER WHICH IS.
HOW MANY OF US CAN ACTUALLY
REMEMBER? WHAT PAINT WAS ON THE
WALLS OF OUR HOMES WHEN WE WERE
LITTLE KIDS AND IF IT TURNED OUT
THAT WE? BECAME POISONED
BECAUSE A LEAD PAINT AND OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WERE
POISONED AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN. ARE POISONED AND I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHETHER THE PAIN
TO MY WALLS FROM SHERWIN
WILLIAMS. OR CONAGRA OR.
NATIONAL LEAD INDUSTRIES AND
THEY FIGHT THIS FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AN ACCORD WHOLESOME LIABLE
AND THEN THEY DECIDE TO GO TO
THE BALLOT. AND POTENTIALLY WITH
A VOTE IN NOVEMBER THEIR
LIABILITY WOULD GO AWAY.
THE QUESTION TO YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE NOW THE FACE OF THE
OPPOSITION HERE IS WHAT ARE WE
THIS AYE IT'S A IT'S A
RHETORICAL QUESTION BECAUSE. I
ASSUME. YOU HAVE AN ANSWER THAT
SUGGESTS THAT INDUSTRY SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO PAY FOR THIS.
IF YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT ANSWER.
HOW MUCH THEY SHOULD PAY IF THEY
SHOULD PAY THEIR ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS? THAT'S A
DIFFERENT THING BUT MY GUESS IS
THAT'S NOT YOUR PERSPECTIVE. OF
BUT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO GRAPPLE WITH HERE.
SO YOU HAVE.
AGAIN I JUST REITERATE WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THE BALLOT WE
HAVEN'T SUPPORTED THAT AND WE
HAVE NO POSITION ON THE
UNDERLYING CASE AND SO AGAIN AT
THAT CASE STANDS IN THEIR PAIN
THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
THE COURT FOUND THAT THEY
MANUFACTURED THE PRODUCT. THAT
HARM THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD
THAT'S CREEK CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT HAS ALREADY SPOKEN THEY'VE
YEAH BUT IMPORTS SYSTEM HAS
SAID.
THEY ARE LIABLE FOR ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS NOW THEY'RE
GOING TO THE PUBLIC.
I'M TRYING TO DECEIVE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING THROUGH
DECEPTIVE ADVERTISING BY
SENDING.
LEGISLATORS OFFICES HUNDREDS OF
EMAILS.
AND AND A AND PUSHING FORTH
MESSAGES THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY.
PLEASE THE DECEPTIVELY FALSE
SO I'D
AYE DON'T IT I'M NOT GOING TO
DISPUTE THAT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THOSE EMAILS OR ANYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON AGAIN WERE NOT INVOLVED
IN THE CAMPAIGN ON THE
INITIATIVE BUT HERE. AGAIN I
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
HOLD ANY COMPANY LIABLE FOR THE
HARM THAT WAS CREATED BY A
DIFFERENT COMPANY THAT CREATED
THE PRODUCT SO NO LIABILITY
KNOWN FOR THE COMPANIES THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PRODUCT
YET NO LIABILITY I DON'T THINK
THAT THEY. ANYONE WHO'S THAT.
MARKETED OR PROMOTED LED PIGMENT
FOR CERAMICS SHOULD BE WITHHELD
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT LIABLE FOR
LEAD PAINT THAT WAS UTILIZED
INSIDE A HOME AN EXPOSE CHILDREN
TO LEAD POISON I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A FAIR DUE PROCESS
ANALYSIS. IF YOU HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE PRODUCT THAT YOU
SHOULD SOMEHOW NOW BE HUNDRED
PERCENT ON THE HOOK THAT'S OUR
CONCERN AND I APPRECIATE WE
COULD PROBABLY HAVE A LONG
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS.
BUT LISTEN AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE LEAD PAINT COMPANIES ARE
THE NEW TOBACCO COMPANIES OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
ANOTHER WORDS AFTER MANY MANY
DECADES OF DECEIVING THE PUBLIC
KNOWING.
AND INTENTIONALLY DECEIVING THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THEIR
PRODUCTS.
THERE NOW TRY TO ESCAPE
LIABILITY THROUGH WHATEVER WAY
THEY CAN.
THEY TRY TO DO TO THE COURT
SYSTEM THE COURT SYSTEM FOUND
THEM LIABLE NOW THEY'RE TRYING
TO GO TO THE BALLOT. WHAT WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING IS ARE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOMEONE IS GOING
TO PAY FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE BEING POISONED?
BY LEAD AND I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYTHING.
TO SUGGEST FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT THERE IS A WAY FOR US TO DO
THIS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION TO TRY AND
RESOLVE THE ISSUE.
BUT I WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT APPROACH WITH
REGARDS TO ALL COMPANIES IN THE
STREAM ACCREDITS MBA AND WAITING
WAITING FOR THE RIGHT APPROACH
BUT WE BEAT SUPPORTIVE.
AT TRYING TO LOOK AT A.
HOLISTIC.
YOU KNOW WHERE'S LEAD COMING
FROM POWER KIDS GETTING EXPOSED
WHO CAUSED THE DAMAGE HOW MUCH
OF IT IS NATURAL WHAT WE DO IS A
STATE. WHERE DOES THE FUNDING
COME FROM ALL OF THOSE ARE GOOD
DISCUSSIONS TO HAVE THAT WOULD
BE ONE TO SIT DOWN AT THE TABLE
WITH?
CREATING LITIGATION AND WE DON'T
THINK IT'S GOING TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT I THINK
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS AT
THIS TIME AGAIN COMPANIES WHO
MARKETED AT FALSELY ADVERTISE TO
CONSUMERS. WHO HAD INTERNAL
DOCUMENTS SAYING THEY KNEW THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO?
THIS WAS GOING TO IMPACT QUOTE
NEGRO AND PER WRITTEN FAMILIES.
THE IMPACTS THAT WE'VE SEEN
AROUND THE STATE ARE AND NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTERS.
SAYING THAT SOMEHOW HOMEOWNERS
OR LIABILITY FOR FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
.
WE WE WE DON'T HAVE SOLUTIONS
AND AND AND LESS YOU CAN TELL US
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE. I
THINK WE NEED WE NEED DIFFERENT
WAYS TO GO OUT THE SO WITH THAT
I AM OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND FROM THE THREATS
MISCHA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR I I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY ARE
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUICK
QUESTIONS THAT I MAY. ALTHOUGH
THE LANGUAGE SHELL DOES SAY THAT
THE INJURED PARTY MAY ESTABLISH
A PRIMA FACIE CASE THAT A
PARTICULAR PARTY. OUGHT IS THE
CAUSE OF THE INJURY OF THE
INJURED PARTY PROVES BY
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE.
THAT A PARTY PRODUCE SOLD
DISTRIBUTED OR PROMOTED.
THE TYPE OF LEAD PAINT ON
PIGMENT THAT CAUSED INJURY MY
QUESTION DEALS WITH THE WORD
PROMOTED.
ARM I I THINK I THINK IT KIND OF
TIES BACK TO THE EXAMPLE GIVEN
BY THE OPPOSITION AND THAT IS
ARE LET'S SAY IF THE LA TIMES
DID DAHLE KIND OF PROMOTE. OUR
YOU KNOW THE USE OF LEAD PAINT
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT DID THE LA
TIMES BE A HELD LIABLE. ARE IT
IN THIS A SCHEME OF THINGS.
AND IF IF IT'S SO YOU KNOW HOW
HOW.
HOW WHY WOULD IT DOES BUT IT
COVER?
SO I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND THE LA TIMES THE OAKLAND
SHOULD. OTHER PUBLICATIONS THAT
RAN ADS FOR LEAD BASED PAINTS
THAT IS SIMPLY ALL THAT THEY DID
IT THEY DID NOT AFFIRMATIVELY
PROMOTE LEAD PAINT FOR USE IN
HOMES IN THE WAY THAT THE.
DEFENDANTS IN OUR LAWSUIT DID
AND THAT THE WAY THAT THE REST
OF THE LEAD INDUSTRY DEAD AND
ACTUALLY WERE AS WELL AS LONG AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE INDICIA
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS VERTICALLY
VERTICALLY. IN INTEGRATED
INDUSTRIES WHERE COMPANIES LIKE
SHERWIN WILLIAMS AND THEY WENT
FROM MINE TO STORE SO THEY WHERE
THE PRODUCERS THEY WORD THE
DISTRIBUTORS THEY WHERE THE
PROMOTERS THEY WERE THE SELLERS.
THEY ON THE MINDS THE SMELTERS
THE REFINERIES THE RETAIL STORES
ETCETERA THEY HANDLED EVERY
ASPECT FROM PRODUCTION SET SAIL.
AND SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROMOTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE TYPES OF PROMOTIONAL
ACTIVITIES WHERE THEY
AFFIRMATIVELY PUT OUT THEY
CREATED THE ADS THEY DISSEMINATE
THE ADS THEY PRODUCED HANDBOOKS
AND JINGLES. THAT TOLD THAT
CONSUMERS TO USE OUR PRODUCT IN
YOUR HOMES WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT NEWSPAPERS THAT SIMPLY
PUBLISHED THE ADS THAT WERE
CREATED.
IF EVERY NEWSPAPER BECAME
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND WRONGDOING
THAT WAS PERPETRATED BY THE
PUBLISHING OF ADS IN THEIR
PAPERS THEY WOULD LONG BE OUT OF
BUSINESS. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE WAY THAT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WORKS I DON'T THINK
THAT'S HOW COURTS WOULD
INTERPRET THIS STATUTE IF
ADOPTED. IT THIS BILL IF
ADOPTED.
THIS IS ALL SUCH A.
I I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROMOTED PASSED.
OUR LANGUAGE
SO.
IN YOUR DEFENSE OF OF MR CAO
QUESTION.
YOU SUGGESTED THAT THE COMPANY
THAT WOULD BE OTHERWISE LIABLE
GIVEN THE OTHER VERBS WE USED IN
THE US OUT ALSO PROMOTED AND
THEN YOU WENT ON TO TALK ABOUT
JINGLES AND I'M THINKING PR
AGENCIES AND. AND.
GROUPS OF PEOPLE THAT MAYBE HAD
ZERO KNOWLEDGE ABOUT ON THE
DANGERS OF LEAD PAINT.
WHO?
WHY IS THAT WERE NECESSARY WHO
ARE YOU? CAPTURING THAT WOULDN'T
OTHERWISE BE CAPTURED ON AND WHY
DO WE NEED THE WORD PROMOTED.
YET SO I LOOK AT IT I WILL GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
ON THE LAWSUIT THAT WE FILED
WITHIN NINE OTHER CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THIS CASE. M. ARE AT
HIGHER. PUBLIC NUISANCE BECAUSE
OF ACTION WAS PREDICATED UPON
PROMOTION SO THAT DEFENDANTS IN
OUR CASE WERE FOUND LIABLE FOR
CREATING A PUBLIC NUISANCE IN
OUR TEN JURISDICTIONS. FOR
THEIR.
NOT JUST PROMOTE AT PRODUCTION
OF LEAD PAINT NOT JUST FOR
PUTTING UP DANGEROUS PRODUCT
INTO THE STREAM OF COMMERCE NOT
JUST FOR SELLING A DANGEROUS
PRODUCT BUT FOR THEIR
AFFIRMATIVE PROMOTION. OF OF
LEAD PAINT WHILE KNOWING ABOUT
HOW DANGEROUS IT WAS WHILE
KNOWING THAT IT WAS GOING TO
CREATE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT AFFIRMATIVE
PROMOTION THAT WAS FAR MORE
EGREGIOUS THAN PUTTING A
DANGEROUS PRODUCT INTO THE
STREAM OF COMMERCE THAT'S WHAT
THEY WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
AND THAT'S WHAT. EXISTING PUBLIC
NUISANCE LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
LIABILITY FOR SO SO MAYBE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SENTENCE
SHOULD INCLUDE AND PROMOTED
RATHER THAN OR PROMOTED.
THAT'S ONE POSSIBILITY ALTHOUGH
AND IF YOU AGAIN AN EXAMPLE OF
SOMEBODY WHO PROMOTED. LEAD
PAINT.
THAT YOU NEED THE STAND ALONE
TERM PROMOTED WITHOUT TYING IT
TO KNOWLEDGE
SOME SORT CONSTRUCTING KNOWLEDGE
OF OF.
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTING THAT
REQUIRES US TO KEEP AYE I'M.
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT MAKING ME MORE
COMFORTABLE YOU'RE MAKING ME
MORE UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE I AM.
UNCLEAR AT WHO YOU'RE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO GET OUT AND IT SEEMS
THAT THERE COULD BE.
FOLKS WHO MAY BE OUR SHOULD NOT
BE HELD LIABLE YEAH AND ONE WAY
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THIS IS BY SAYING. THAT IT'S THE
PROMOTERS WHO HAD KNOWLEDGE OF
THE HARMS THAT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BEAT THAT WOULD RESULT FROM
THE LEAD PAINT THAT THEY ARE
PROMOTING. THANK YOU AND I'M TO
THE AUTHOR I I ASSUME WE'LL
WE'LL SEE SOME OF THESE CHANGES
IF THE* OUT TODAY. YEAH GOOD
POINT SET SUCH WHAT I'M A
LISTENING TO OPPOSITIONS POINTS
CONCERNS FROM THAT ARE MY
COLLEAGUES AND.
I'M TAKING CAREFUL NOTES HERE
ABOUT SOME WASTE IMPROVE THE
BILL STRENGTHENED TECHNIQUE.
THERE HAS BEEN A SECOND WE DO
HAVE EMOTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT.
SO.
MISTRESS IN THIS REMINDS ME SO
MUCH OF THE ASBESTOS CASES WE
HAD SO MANY PEOPLE WHO WERE
INJURED IN TRYING TO FIND THE
MANUFACTURERS. TRYING TO FIND
THOSE UNTIL FINALLY THAT THE
ISSUE WAS RESOLVED I THINK WE
ARE HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE CHILDREN ARE
SUFFERING IRREPARABLE HARM.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE
FOR THESE CHILDREN THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED AND THEY WILL SUFFER THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES BECAUSE OF
THIS EXPOSURE. AND TO MAKE IT
EVEN MORE EGREGIOUS IS THE FACT
THAT THE LEAD OR THE PINK
COMPANIES KNEW WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
THAT'S WHY AFTER THE EIGHTEEN
YEARS FINALLY THEY ARE FOUND.
A LIABLE THEY'RE TOLD TO PUT THE
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS UP
AS A FUND BECAUSE OF THISIS.
THE DAMAGE THEY'VE ALREADY
BECAUSE.
THERE WERE SOME.
STUDIES THAT WERE SHARED WITH US
ALSO. IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT THE
COST OF ABATEMENT VERSUS THE
COST OF HAVING TO KNOW CARE FOR
THESE CHILDREN WHO WERE EXPOSED.
BECAUSE OF AND I I I AGREE WITH
MY MY COLLEAGUE.
WE HAVE TO INCLUDE THE WORD
GREED IN THIS.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE GREED OF THE
THE PAINT COMPANIES KNOWING THAT
THEY WERE STILL MAKING MONEY ON
THE BACKS ON THE LIVES OF THESE
CHILDREN.
SO I I'M GLAD THAT YOU'VE
INTRODUCES LEGISLATION I'M GLAD
THAT THEIR COMMENTS ABOUT SOME
WAYS TO MAKE IT BETTER MAKE IT
STRONGER. BUT I THINK THE ENTIRE
IDEA BEHIND YOUR BILL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND IT IS
SOMETHING NECESSARY.
TO HELP THOSE CHILDREN THAT ARE
GOING TO SUFFER FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES SO I THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AND I.
SEEING NONE MISTER BONTA MIKLOS
YEAH I JUST WANNA THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION FOR FOR FOR
POINTING OUT THEIR CONCERNS MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SHARING WITH ME
THERE'S. AND I'M GONNA TAKE A
CLOSE LOOK AT THESE ISSUES THAT
AND REYES AND AND DO OUR BEST AS
WE ALWAYS DO IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO STRENGTHEN THE BILL
AND AND MAKE IT TIGHTER.
YOU KNOW IT IN THE END.
WE HAVE
CHILDREN AND OTHERS WHO ARE
INNOCENT VICTIMS AND AMBER
POISONED.
BY PEDDLERS OF LEAD PAINT
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND THERE WAS A DUTY.
AND A BREACH OF THAT DUTY BY THE
DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS.
AND.
WE HAVE A VICTIM WHO'S BEEN
HURT.
BY A CERTAIN TYPE OF OF LEAD
PAINT PIGMENT.
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHICH OF THE
MANY.
NEGLIGENT ACTORS IS THE ONE WHO
CAUSED IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RECORDS TIME
IS PAST RECORDS HAVE BEEN.
LOST OR MAYBE NEVER EXISTED.
AND THEY KNOW THEY'VE BEEN HURT
AND SO ALL THIS BILL SAYS IS
IN IT WHAT DO YOU DO ON THAT
OCCASION DO YOU DO YOU LET. THE
NEGATIVE ACTORS STAND AS A GROUP
POINT ONE ANOTHER AND SAY IT MAY
HAVE BEEN THE OTHER WHAT NOT ME.
THAT YOU CAN'T PROVE EXACTLY WHO
IT IS WE ALL GET OFF SCOT FREE.
THAT'S WRONG.
WE HAVE OUR LAW HAS ADDRESSED
THAT VERY ISSUE MULTIPLE TIMES
WHETHER IT BE WITH THINGS LIKE
RACE IPSO LOCKWOOD OR THE SUMMER
VERSUS TYPES ALTERNATE LIABILITY
CASE.
WE'VE WE'VE ADDRESSED THAT AND
WE'VE HAD BURDEN SHIFTING IN
OTHER OCCASIONS AND AND WE HAVE
IT NOW AND AND IT'S A POLICY
RECENT AND IT IT SET FORTH VERY
CLEARLY IN THE COLLINS CASE.
IT SAYS THAT THAT THIS RULE THIS
THIS BURDEN SHIFTING WHICH
CHEFS.
I'M THE BURDEN OF CAUSATION TO
THE DEFENDANT.
IT REPRESENTS A POLICY
DETERMINATION THAT AN INNOCENT
PLAINTIFF
SHOULD NOT BE WITHOUT REMEDY.
BECAUSE HE OR SHE IS UNABLE TO
PERFECT TO PROVE WHICH OF THE
NEGLIGENT DEFENDANTS BECAUSE THE
HEART.
EXACTLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
THERE WAS NEGLIGENCE
HARM WAS CAUSED SOMEONE WAS HURT
THEY WERE POISONED AN INNOCENT
CHILD IN MANY CASES AND THEY
JUST DON'T KNOW WHICH OF THE
MANY NEGATIVE ACTORS IT WAS. THE
MAJOR ACTORS KNOW WHAT THEY DID
THEY HAVE THEIR RECORDS THEY CAN
PROVE THAT THEY DIDN'T
DISTRIBUTE THE PAINT AND A
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHIC AREA OR AT A
CERTAIN TIME. THEY HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO AND I'M SURE THAT
THEY WEREN'T THE ONE. OUT BUT WE
SHOULDN'T BE GIVING.
THAT THE BAD ACTORS IMMUNITY
WHILE WE DISALLOW INNOCENT
POISON CHILDREN FROM
AND JUSTICE
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AGO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MOTION IS DO PATH OF
COLOR PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN NO
RADIUS.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU IT WAS
BUT I DO KNOW YOU HAVE TO BILLS
BUT IF YOU COULD YIELD FROM
MISTER LEVINE HE SPENT. VERY
PACE AND THEY SHOULD GO VERY
QUICKLY APPETITE.
AND ALSO TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA BUT LET ME
EXPLAIN ESSENTIAL LITTLE BIT
THERE BEEN TO ITEMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PULLED OFF THE CONSENT
AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX CERVANTES
AND WE WILL HEAR THAT BILL NEXT
WEEK.
AND ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB THREE
ZERO FOUR ONE CUNNINGHAM WHICH
JUDGE THAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY.
YES WE WILL BE HEARING THAT ONE
TODAY SO WITH THOSE CHANGES TAKE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
YOU HAVE A MOTION SIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU BERMAN.
BUT.
YEAH.
STATE YOUR NAME.
ABOUT.
YES.
YES THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I. CHOW. CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN. MAINTAIN
IRIS.
REYES I.
KALRA CALDERON CONSENT CONSENT
BY.
THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT THAT IS
NUMBER.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY FOUR HOLDEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY IRWIN AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY BLOOM AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY TWO
CALDERON.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN THE
RUBIO.
A. B. THREE ZERO SIX SIX STONE
AND A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT
WHICH IS A JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BILL.
BUT TO LIVING YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORKON THIS BILL AND
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS HAS PROPOSED. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWO WHICH INCREASES THE
NUMBER OF NON PROFITABLE
CORPORATIONS
THAT WOULD QUALIFY TO APPLY.
TO OFFER GUARDIANSHIP TO IT
UNACCOMPANIED SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILES
IN OTHER MINERS WHEN DETAINED
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN FEDERAL
CUSTODY CANNOT BE RELEASED TO AN
APPROPRIATE FAMILY MEMBER OR
OTHER ADULT THEY CAN BE
ELIGIBLE.
FOR LONG TERM FOSTER CARE
THROUGH THE FEDERAL SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY STATE LAW LIMITED
TO ORGANIZATIONS DIED
INCORPORATED IN CALIFORNIA THIS
WILL EXPAND THIS TO BEING. A
CORPORATE OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA FOR
AGENCIES ALREADY OUT LICENSE
HERE IN THE STATE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES WITH ME TO PROVIDE
FURTHER TESTIMONY. I HAVE
THE CIVIC INDIA OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN ABIGAIL
TRILLIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR.
THANK YOU AND I JUST ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS FROM.
THE AND BURKE CLARIFICATION THE
AMENDMENTS ROXY TAKEN
BEFORE COMING AS IT CAME INTO
THE COMMITTEES SO THERE'S NOT A
MOMENT THAT WERE TAKING GOING
OUT JUST I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE I BRING TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THAT'S HARD ON AYE. YEAH
I MEAN IF YOU WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ARE ACTUALLY PART
OF THE BILL THAT'S IN FRONT OF
US THANK YOU AND THE RECOMMENDED
MOTIONS JUST TO PASS.
SO WE'RE SETTLEMENT THANK YOU.
FIRST.
WHEN THIS PLACE THINK YOU.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU WITH THIS
PLEASE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ABIGAIL CHILLIN AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN ON OUR AGENCY. MEETS
WITH EVERY UNACCOMPANIED
IMMIGRANT CHILD WHO IS DETAINED
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BY THE
OFFICE OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
BY A FEDERAL AGENCY.
THAT HAS BEEN IN THREE
DIFFERENT FACILITIES AND NOW
THERE'S BEEN A FOURTH PROGRAM AT
A WHICH IS A FEDERAL FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM AND THE REASON WHY
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE.
THERE ARE MORE AND MORE CHILDREN
WHO ARE NOT RELEASED FROM
FEDERAL DETENTION TO FAMILY
MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY'RE SO MUCH
MORE FEAR IN THE COMMUNITY.
OF COMING FORWARD AND SO MANY
MORE CHILDREN ARE AND WILL BE.
SPENDING MORE AND MORE TIME IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY AND SO OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T WANT THOSE CHILDREN IN
SHELTERS OUR DETENTION
FACILITIES WE WANT THEM AND
FAMILY SO THIS THAT. THE COMING
ON OF THIS FEDERAL FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A REALLY GOOD
NEWS FOR FORT FOR CHILDREN IN
OUR AREA.
AND THE PROBLEM IS BECAUSE.
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM AND
OTHERS THAT COULD COME ON ARE
BASED IN ANOTHER STATE EVEN
OTHER LICENSED HERE THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO SERVICE GUARDIANS WHICH
PRECLUDES A FORM OF IMMIGRATION
RELIEF CALLED SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS. ON AS ADVOCATES
FOR CHILDREN WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF THE CHILDREN
THAT WE REPRESENT CAN PURSUE ANY
FORM OF IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
AVAILABLE TO THEM WE NEVER WANT
THEM TO HAVE TO CHOOSE ON TO
GIVE ONE OF THOSE FORMS OF
RELIEF UP IN ORDER TO TAKE A
PLACEMENT THAT'S IN THEIR BEST
INTERESTS THESE ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF THE VULNERABLE
IMMIGRANTS THESE ARE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN WHO DO
NOT HAVE FAMILY HERE. TO BE
RELEASED TO ON AND THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCE EXTREME TRAUMA WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE IN THE
BEST POSSIBLE ENVIRONMENT.
WHICH WE BELIEVE IT'S A ARE
THESE FAMILY HOMES AND WE DON'T
WANT TO GIVE UP SOMETHING IN
THEIR IMMIGRATION CASE IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE SERVICES.
SO WE THINK YOU ON FOR HEARING
THIS BILL THIS MORNING OUT.
AND I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
ONE OF OUR TRAITS TO JUST TALK
ABOUT SPECIFIC CASES TO GET.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU MY NAME CECILIA CANDY
I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT ONE CHILD
THAT I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH.
I'M GONNA CALL HER KLAUDIA.
.
SHE'S A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL
FROM THE CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRY.
HER FATHER ABANDONED THE FAMILY
HE WAS AN ALCOHOLIC AND
EVENTUALLY DISAPPEARED INTO
SUPPORT THE FAMILY.
CLAUDIA AND HER MOTHER.
AND HER YOU LITTLE SIBLINGS
WERE LEFT DESTITUTE IN VERY
POOR.
.
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY OFTEN
DID NOT HAVE FOOD AND THE
CHILDREN WENT HUNGRY.
LAWYERS THE OLDEST CHILD BEGAN
WORKING AT A VERY YOUNG AGE NOT
TWELVE YEARS OLD HE HAD TO QUIT
SCHOOL IN ORDER TO WORK FULL
TIME.
AND WHEN SHE WAS FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD SHE LEFT HER FAMILY AND
TRAVELED BY HERSELF ON A BUS
TO THE CAPITAL CITY IN THAT
COUNTRY TO WORK AS AN LIVIN
DOMESTIC WORKER.
SHE WORKED TWELVE HOUR DAYS SIX
DAYS A WEEK WASHING CLEANING
TAKING CARE OF THE CHILDREN AND
SHOPPING FOR THE FOOD.
SHE WAS WITHOUT FAMILY IN A
STRANGE ENVIRONMENT WITH ADULTS
AND SHE WAS VERY VULNERABLE.
WHEN SHE WAS OUTSIDE OF THE
HOUSE ESPECIALLY MEN WOULD HAVE.
PROPOSITION HER.
OFFER HER MONEY TO LAY DOWN WITH
THEM TO SLEEP BUT THEM. AND SHE
DECLINED OR IGNORED THEM AND TRY
TO RUN AWAY.
EVENTUALLY THIS ESCALATED WERE
THEY CHASED HER.
STUNTS DOCTOR AND EVENTUALLY
SHE WAS THREATENED TO BE RAPED
SEVERAL TIMES.
SHE WAS SO AFRAID THAT SHE CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THALIA IS OBVIOUSLY A A CHILD
CLEARLY QUALIFIES FOR SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS HER
FATHER ABANDONED HER AND IT'S
NOT IN HER BEST INTEREST TO
RETURN TO HOME HOME COUNTRY. BUT
SHE THROUGH NO FAULT OF HER OWN
CANNOT PURSUE THIS FORM OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF JUST BECAUSE
OF WHERE SHE HAS PLACED.
SHE'S LIVING WITH A WONDERFUL
FAMILY AND SHE'S IN A FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM APPEAR IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT. SHE IS UNABLE TO
PURSUE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
I INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
RACHEL PAINTING IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER WHERE A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
I RODRIGUEZ CENTER BELL
IMPOUNDMENT LINES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
ANYWHERE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF REAR BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CUMMINS.
SINGER MISCELLANY MIKLOS.
EXCEPT PERHAPS FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MOTION IS DO
PASS.
TOTAL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RACE AYE REYES
AYE.
THAT BILLS THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S.
RIGHT SO MISTER BONTA ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE
.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING US.
OF COURSE MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
STAFF THANK YOU PICK UP TO NEED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE.
AND FOR THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT INTO THIS
MEASURE I WILL BE MAKING THE
AMENDMENTS FOUND A PAGE FOUR AND
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU
FOR THOSE. SEVENTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS RENT THE PLACE THEY
CALL HOME.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS
LANDLORDS TO EVICT TENANTS
WITHOUT PROVIDING A REASON.
FOR OF ACTION WITH WITH GROWING
HOUSING COSTS LACK OF HOUSING.
APPLY IN SHORT EVICTION NOTICES
FINDING A NEW PLACE TO LIVE
AFTER BEING EVICTED CAN BE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FAMILIES WHO
ARE AFFECTED CAN BE PUSHED INTO
HOMELESSNESS.
OR UNSTABLE SHELTER FOR MONTHS
OR YEARS
FOLLOWING EVICTION UNJUSTIFIED
EVICTIONS BECAUSE LOS
DISPLACEMENT AND HARDSHIP ON
FAMILIES.
ACROSS THE STATE.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE SEEKS
TO PREVENT DISCRIMINATORY
ARBITRARY OR RETALIATORY
EVICTIONS AND ENSURE THAT
EVICTIONS ARE FAIR AND JUST.
THIS BILL REQUIRES PROPERTY
OWNERS TO PROVIDE TENANTS A
CAUSE FOR ADDICTION
IN THE NOTICE OF EVICTION.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT TENANTS WHO HAVE
FOLLOWED THE RULES ABIDED BY THE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF THEIR
LEASE AND PAY THE RENT ON TIME.
DO NOT LOSE THE PLACE THEY CALL
HOME DUE TO CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
FORECLOSURE OF PROPERTY. OR
EXPIRATION OF A FIXED TERM
LEASE.
THE HISTORY CULTURE AND
CHARACTER OF OUR COMMUNITIES
SUFFER WHEN RESIDENTS LIVE WITH
NO HOUSING SECURITY FORCING THEM
TO MOVE FROM HOME. TO HOME AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE WILL
HELP PROTECT CALIFORNIAN TENANTS
FROM LIVING IN UNCERTAINTY.
HOPING THEY ARE NOT UNJUSTLY
EVICTED FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT
JUST CAUSE OF ACTION POLICIES
PROTECT MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS THE. ELDERLY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
PROVIDING THEM A STABLE HOUSING
IN THE MIDST OF A DEVASTATING
HOUSING CRISIS.
MEMBERS ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS EFFORT TO
PROTECT OUR TENANTS
AND HELP KEEP A SAFE AND SECURE
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS DEEMED
PASSED AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
TENET'S TOGETHER CHRIS THE GRACE
ASORIO TENET NOW MEDIA. AND MAKE
IT A BALLOT DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
AND ORGANIZING FOR TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE.
THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TEAM PRESIDENT SECULAR
DIRECTOR OF TENANTS TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION FOR RENTERS RIGHTS
I WORK COALITION A FIFTY. A
LOCAL TENANT ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE WORKING TO
PROTECT AND ADVANCE THE RIGHTS
OF A CALIFORNIA TENANTS TO SAFE
DECENT.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE APPRECIATE AYE MR BONTA AS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT TO BAN ARBITRARY
ADDICTION I IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS A MISTER CHOOSE CO
AUTHORSHIP OF THE BILL.
TENANTS TOGETHER HAS OPERATED
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY STATEWIDE
RENTERS RIGHTS HOTLINE FOR
NEARLY A DECADE UP THROUGH THAT
HOTLINE WE COUNSELED OVER TEN
THOUSAND A TENANT HOUSEHOLDS.
WE DEAL WITH TENANTS EVERYDAY
FROM ACROSS THE STATE WHO WERE
EVICTED FOR NO GOOD REASON FOR
NO REASON AT ALL AND PREDICTION
NOTICES THAT DO NOT STATE.
BECAUSE FOR OF ACTION AND
PARTICULARLY IN THIS HOUSING
CRISIS THESE CONVICTIONS ARE
HEARTBREAKING.
THE LANDLORDS IN THESE VICTIMS
DO NOT STATE A REASON FOR
EVICTION BECAUSE THE LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRE THEM TO DO SO MANY
OF OUR CALLERS ARE ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKED WHEN THEY CALL OUR
HOTLINE. AND FIND OUT THAT IT IS
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA TO VICTOR
TENANT WITHOUT EVEN STATE
STATING THE REASON FOR THE
OBJECTION.
MOST OF THE IS NO FAULT OF
ACTIONS AND NO BECAUSE OF
ACTIONS.
ARE IT RETALIATORY SITUATIONS
WHERE LANDLORDS HAVE REQUESTED
REPAIRS.
AND THEN THE LANDLORD THE
TENANT REQUEST REPAIRS THE
LAMBERT RESPONSE OUT WITH
EVICTION NOTICE THAT DOES NOT
STATE. THE REASON FOR EVICTION I
WANNA POINT OUT ONE THING AND
THAT IS FEATURED IN THE
OPPOSITION HA ARGUMENTS WHICH
IS.
THAT SOMEHOW THIS BILL WILL
MAKE IT HARDER TO EVICT TENANTS
WHO ENGAGE IN ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE THEIR
SEPARATE PROVISIONS IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. THAT ALLOW FOR
EVICTION ON THREE DAYS NOTICE OF
TENANTS WHO ARE ALLEGED TO HAVE
ENGAGED IN ANY KIND OF
MISCONDUCT OR BROKEN THEIR LEASE
OR FAILED TO PAY THE RENT. THIS
BILL DOES NOT TOUCH THOSE
EVICTIONS IN ANY WAY.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE LANGUAGE THE STATE THE
REASON IF THEY CHOOSE TO VICTOR
TENANTS WITH NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK
IT'S A MATTER OF BASIC FAIRNESS.
TENANTS SHOULD NOT LOSE THEIR
HOMES WITHOUT A REASON STATED IN
A NOTICE TO TERMINATE TENDENCY.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
SORIA I WAS ONE OF THE TENETS OF
FOUR SEVENTY CENTRAL AVENUE AND
ALAMEDA WHICH IS HOME TO MOSTLY
FILIPINO IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
A IT WAS BEFORE THE CHRISTMAS OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN MY FAMILY
AND MY FELLOW TENANTS.
ALWAYS HAVE RECEIVED EVICTION
NOTICES.
AND THE NOTICE DID NOT GIVE ANY
SUBSTANTIAL OR JUST RECENT TO
AFFECT US.
OTHER THAN THAT THEY WANTED TO
RENOVATED AND WE HAVE TO RE
APPLY TO COME BACK.
IN.
WHICH WAS NOT EVEN A GUARANTEE
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO
INCREASE THE RENT FOR ALL UNITS.
AND MY FELLOW TENANTS.
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING EVICTION
ATTEMPTS FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
NOW I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN I
GOT THE EVICTION NOTICE AND I'M
NOW HALFWAY THROUGH MY COLLEGE
YEARS AND STILL. JUSTICE IS
STILL NOT SERVE.
AND JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO OUR
FIGHT FOR JUST BECAUSE.
JUST GOT RESCINDED.
IN ALAMEDA AND EVERYDAY THE
TENETS OF FOUR SEVENTY ARE STILL
IN RISK OF ADDICTION AS WELL AS
OTHER TENANTS IN CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT STILL WE RISE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE PASSING OR
EXTENDING MORATORIUM'S WILL NOT
SOLVE THE ROOT PROBLEMS OF THIS
ISSUE.
AND.
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY AND. NOW I
AM HERE SIMPLY ASKING YOU ALL TO
PASS A B. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE. SO THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S
LANDLORDS WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
TO.
GIVE TENANTS A JUST REASON WHY
THEY'RE TRYING TO VEGAS.
AND A JEALOUS I CHARGE THEE ALL
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE AND.
PROVIDE JUSTICE AND PROTECTION
FOR ALL TENANTS IN A CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MEGAN ABLE WITH
TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE.
I. THINK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BILL.
I'M ADVOCACY IN ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR OF THE TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
FIVE.
I THE TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE
IS A MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION AND
WE REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF TECH
WORKERS IN THE BAY AREA.
I. WHEW A BELIEVE THAT THE TECH
ECONOMY CAN AND SHOULD WORK FOR
EVERYONE.
AND WIN VISION OF CALIFORNIA IN
WHICH THE GROWTH OF THE TECH
SECTOR LEADS TO BROAD BASED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
RESIDENTS IN OUR STATE RATHER
THAN DEEPENING IN EQUITY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
COMMONSENSE TENANT PROTECTION.
IS THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS THAT
VISION I WELL THE TECH INDUSTRY
DIDN'T CREATE THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES THAT ARE CAUSING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CRISIS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FAST GROWTH
OF OUR INDUSTRY HAS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE CONDITIONS THAT ARE
PUSHING OUT LONG TERM TENANTS.
AND RESIDENTS I'M FROM BONE
RIPPLE COMMUNITIES.
WE FEEL WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO USE OUR VOICE ADVOCATE FOR
POLICY YOU. AYE THAT WILL MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE WHO
WANTS TO LIVE HERE ACCESS A
STABLE HOUSING AND PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY I'M HERE
TODAY AND MY ORGANIZATION IS
SUPPORTING THE SPELL. THIS BASIC
REFORM HAS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
KEEP TENANTS IN OUR STATE
GUARDED FROM BASELESS
DISPLACEMENT.
NEARLY FORTY SIX PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE IN LIQUID ASSET
POVERTY.
MEANING THAT WHEN MIDDLE AND LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS RECEIVE IN
INCOME SHOCKLEY COULD BE USELESS
ADDICTION THEY'RE OFTEN NOT ABLE
TO WEATHER THE STORM. WE NEED TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS ARE BECAUSE
WE YOU KNOW VERY WELL FROM WHAT
HAPPENED ACROSS THE BAY AREA.
THAT SO. WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
TENANTS FROM DISPLACEMENT AND
THE FIBER OF VIBRANT
COMMUNITIES.
AS MEMBERS OF THE TECH COMMUNITY
WANT TO BE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE RESILIENCY
TO WRITE OUT THE WAVE. AND NOT
BE WASHED OUT AND JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS I ARE NEEDED NOW. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU OTHERS AND SUPPORTS.
BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
I RODRIGUEZ AND BEHALF OF
CENTRAL IMPAIRMENT ALLIANCE AND
SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER HER NAME WITH THE
WESTERN
ALONG PROPERTY AND.
UNTIL CARRILLO MOSCOW CURRENTLY
RESIDING AT FOUR SEVEN ZERO
SHIPPER LOBBY YOU ALAMEDA.
SUPPORT TO BE.
SANDWICH ARTIST.
YOU CANCELING WHO'D BEEN OUT OF
CANCER JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
CYNTHIA BONTA WITH THE FILIPINO
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
STATE FOR LEADING IN THIS.
FACE.
WHEN HE WAS OFTEN TAMAM IN THE
RESIDENT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AS OFFICE.
DISTRICT AND I'M A MILLION
PERCENT.
SUPPORT OF JUST BECAUSE AND WE
NEED TO STOP ALL ADDICTION.
I MEAN IT WAS DC GOT WANNA TEN
ORGANIZER A FILIPINA ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING THIS BILL.
FLIPPING GO WITH FILIPINA
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
SUPPORT.
OUR RUBBER COBURN SECOND
ATTACHING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY BET IS FREEZE ON THE RICHEST
COALITION IN PLEASE I'M SUPPORT
THIS.
TONY GRAHAM FROM THE ALAMEDA
RENTERS COALITION AND SUPPORT
BECAUSE RICHEST DESERVE DUE
PROCESS BEFORE LOSING THEIR
HOMES.
KELLY ROSENBERG WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
LEAGUE PERFORMANCE SUPPORT WEAR
PREACH OF OF THE AUTHORS I WORK
ON THIS AND WE PROBABLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TWO MORE AT THIS BY SAYING THIS
IT GROW THEY OWN THIS OUT THERE
THE NATIONAL WILD IS NETWORK I
SUPPORT.
AND AS PART OF OUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION.
CLEAR THE TABLES FOR OPPOSITION
TO.
COME UP AND GIVE
.
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I DEBRA CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARDON ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY A THIS BILL THAT
THE PROVIDE ANY PROTECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY.
FOR THE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT WE FEAR THAT IT'S
SIMPLY GOING TO LEAD AS WE
INDICATED.
IN OUR LETTER TO INCREASE RENTS
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M SAYING THAT'S THE
UNFORTUNATE PART OF WHAT WE
DON'T NEED TO SEE RITE NOW IN
OUR CURRENT ECONOMIC SITUATION
WITH LACK. OF HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE TO THIS BILL
DOESN'T PREVENT.
LAMBERT FROM RAISING THE RENT.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT JUST
BECAUSE WAS CREATED. IN RENT
CONTROL JURISDICTIONS.
TO PREVENT LANDLORDS FROM SIMPLY
RAISING THE RENT.
A I'D AND MOVING TENANTS OUT TO
RAISE THE RENT.
WE ALREADY HAVE
STATUTES THAT CREATES A
PROHIBITION FOR RETALIATORY
EVICTION WE ALREADY HAVE A
STATUTE. THE PROHIBITS LANDLORDS
FROM TERMINATING A TENDENCY
BECAUSE OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION.
A LANDLORD CAN STILL MOVE IT
TURNED OUT TO DO THE REHAB AS WE
HEARD EARLIER THIS BILL DOESN'T
DO ANY OF THAT.
SO FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS.
WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE.
THANK YOU ALL TAKE TWO MORE
WITNESSES THAT'S WHAT.
THE CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE RUN KINGSTON I
REPRESENT FOR REGIONAL APARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE SPACE SOUTHERN CITIES ORANGE
COUNTY AND.
DORK VALLEY.
WE TO JOIN IN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL. THEIR COUPLE POINTS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE.
IT'S BILL ENCOURAGES OPEN
INTERPRETATION BY EVERY AT A
COURT HEARING AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER. IN ANY DISPUTE THERE'S
NO GUIDANCE IN THIS BILL.
THE CURRENT LAWS ON EVICTION ARE
VERY VERY CLEAR THEY'RE
DIFFERENT THEN WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMINATION
EVICTION IS FOR. NON PAY THAT'S
THE PRINCIPAL REASON FOR IT.
BREACH OF LEAKS.
YOU'RE COMMITTING WASTE YOUR.
YOU'RE DOING A NUMBER OF OTHER.
ELEMENTS WHICH ARE IN VIOLATION
AT LEAST ILLEGAL HOLDOVERS THOSE
ARE EGGS VERY SPECIFIC EXAMPLES.
COURTS ADVISED BY THE PARTIES
THE LYTIC
THE BOTH THE LITIGANTS.
THAT INVOLVED IN THE CASE KNOW
THE RULES
HOWEVER IN THIS THERE ARE NO
RULES IT IS THE WILD WILD WEST
WHEN YOU GO TO COURT.
IF A LANDLORD SPECIFIES WHICH
THIS BILL DOES.
ANY TYPE OF STATEMENT. THE COURT
WILL LEAVE IT TO OPEN
INTERPRETATION.
EVERY DAY THAT THE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING THE PARTIES WILL
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE COURT WILL
FIND AS THE RULES OF THE GAME IF
YOU WILL. WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
IF IT IS A LATE PAY IN THE
SLAMMER DECIDES TO?
PURSUE AGAINST THAT OF MAYBE ONE
COURT SAYS.
THERE ARE FOUR LATE PAYS WHICH
ARE TOLERABLE GIVE THE TENANT
MORE TIME.
SECOND THERE ARE SAID THERE WERE
TWO POINTS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF TIMES WHEN A
LAMB OR CHOOSES TO TERMINATE THE
TENANCY IT'S THE MOST
EXPEDITIOUS Y.. AND THEY DON'T
DO THIS IN A MALICIOUS WAY AS
HAS BEEN. ALLEGED.
THE REASON WHY YOU TERMINATE THE
TENANCY THAT THE TENET IS
PLAYING THE STEREO CONSTANTLY AT
TWO THIRTY AT NIGHT.
AND THE OTHER TENANTS THE GOOD
TENANTS ARE COMPLAINING.
THOSE GOOD TENANTS DO NOT WANT
TO ACT AS A WITNESS THEY WILL
NOT TAKE OFF FROM WORK. THEY
WILL NOT GO TO COURT THEY WILL
THEY WILL CHOOSE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE PATHS.
THEY'LL LEAVE AND VACATE.
CAN LEAVING.
THE TENANT FOR THE OFFENDING
TENET THERE IN RESIDENTS
THE QUESTION BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IS WHO ARE WE TRYING
TO PROTECT LAMBERTS DON'T DO
THIS MALICIOUSLY.
THIS CARLTON POINTED OUT THERE A
NUMBER OF OTHER LAWS ARE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS WHICH WE
HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED.
RETALIATORY EVICTION
PROTECTIONS HABITABILITY THEIR
NUMBERS OF LOS.
SO WE ARE NOT IN A A MYSTERY OR
A BLACK HOLE IF YOU WILL.
KNOWING WHAT A LANDLORDS CONDUCT
MUST BE AND THEY MUST BEAT
STRONGLY ADHERED TO. FOR THESE
AND OTHER REASONS.
PRINCIPALLY BECAUSE THERE ARE
NO GUIDING PRINCIPLES TO THE
COURT. AS TO WHAT THE COURT
SHALL BE DIRECTED TO CONSIDER WE
MUST AND REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
IMMEDIATE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAYS
HE PARLOUS AND FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES IN THE SANTA BARBARA
RENTAL PROPERTY ASSOCIATION.
.
OFTENTIMES WHEN WE'RE UP HERE WE
HERE EXTREME ANECDOTES OF OF
SITUATIONS WHICH NONE OF US
SUPPORT.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY AND
I'M TALKIN THAT NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT OF LANDLORDS TO NOT
EVICT.
GOOD TENANTS.
HAVING A VACANCY IN YOUR
APARTMENT IS WAY MORE COSTLY. OF
THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
SO IT'S AS A LAST RESORT THAT
DAY AND OWNER WLL PURSUE THAT
SO CALLED NO FOR NO FAULT THIRTY
TO SIXTY DAY. TERMINATION.
AND THAT IS AS AS MISTER KING
SENATE'S POINTED OUT TO REALLY
PROTECT THE OTHER TENANTS AND
FOR THE OWNER TO.
SUPPORT HIS OR HER DUTY.
TO MAINTAIN THE QUIET ENJOYMENT
FOR THE OTHER TENANTS.
WE DON'T SUPPORT.
.
JUST BECAUSE EVICTION.
CITIES ARE ENTITLED TO ENACT
JUST CAUSE OF ACTION.
IT'S BEEN FIFTEEN OR EIGHTEEN
CITIES
SOME OF WHICH HAVE RENT CONTROL
SOME OF WHICH DO NOT THEY'RE
FREE TO DO SO.
.
FOR ITS THE STATE NOW TO IMPOSE
ITS WILL ON THIS ISSUE.
WE BELIEVE WILL HAVE SO MANY
ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
GOOD TENANTS.
WITH AND WE BUT LIKE THE THE
COMMITTEE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
THAT AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
MUST. RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE THE BILL.
I'M LIKE I COULD TAKE MORE TO
SOMEBODY BUT YOU CAN JUST GIVE
YOUR NAME AND.
OPPOSITION THANK YOU JIM LIGHTS
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL RENTAL
HOME COUNCIL COMPRISED OF
COMPANIES THAT OWN A SINGLE
FAMILY RENTAL PROPERTIES AND NOW
WITH THE POLICIES TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA WHERE LATE
OPPONENTS TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
AYE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PATRON
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WERE POSED FOR
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF CREAM THREE CM HALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR
THE REASONS PEOPLE HE'S
PREVIOUSLY STATED RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU KNOW VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SINGLE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
KALRA.
THANK YOU SHARE OF AND THINK YOU
OF MISTER BONTA JUST WIND UP IN
A CLARIFICATION THE. ONLY CITY
IN MY JURISDICTION OF SAN JOSE
WE HAVE OUR OWN.
OF ORDINANCE REGARDING JUST
BECAUSE I WAS PUT INTO PLACE
LAST YEAR MY READING OF THE BILL
IS THAT.
IT IT.
.
WELL REMAINS IN PLACE THEY
ALTHOUGH THE LOCAL ORDINANCES
BECAUSE SOUNDS DAYS ACTUALLY
LIST TWELVE SPECIFIC.
INSTANCES OF MINE THAT.
JUST BECAUSE CAN BE A VOTE IN
ITS AND THEY'RE PRETTY BROAD AND
DEAL WITH A NEW SENSE AND ALL
OTHER RANGE OF. OF A DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES AND BEHAVIORS
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT ORDERS BUT
HAVE YOU.
THAT BEING SAID I DO LIKE THE
FACT THAT IT THAT THE BILL DOES
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO TAKE THAT STEP.
I THINK THAT.
.
YEAH THAT IF THERE ARE SOME
DOWNWARD PRESSURE TO DO THAT.
I'D LIKE TO BE A GOOD THING I
THINK IT WAS IT WAS AN EASY
PROCESS PUBLICITY GO THROUGH
BECAUSE THE OTHER A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN DIFFICULT HEARINGS BUT
I THINK THAT'S THE ROLE OF OF. A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO GO TO THAT
PROSTITUTE BUT IT'S BEST FOR
THEM. AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE THE. THE ANY DEGREE OF.
CONCERN A CRITICISM THAT THIS
IS TOO BROAD BECAUSE NOT A
SPECIFICITY WELL LOCAL
ORDINANCES CAN ADD THAT
SPECIFICITY SPECIFICITY AS IT
SUITS THEIR JURISDICTION AND
THAT'S WHAT SAN JOSE DID AND AND
SO GIVEN THE FACT. THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT SUPERSEDE THE WORK
THAT WAS DONE.
A BY THEJURISDICTION I
REPRESENT.
I'M CERTAINLY COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING IT AND HOPE THAT
OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TAKE
THE ACTIONS THAT. THE DIFFICULT
ACTIONS THAT SOUNDS A DID TO
COME TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY AND
DETERMINE WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
BOTH THE LANDLORDS AS WELL AS
THE TENANTS.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISERY.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE YOUNG
WOMAN WHO TESTIFIED EARLIER
ABOUT BEING EVICTED AND HER
EXPERIENCE I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO HEAR THOSE
EXPERIENCES.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
AND IT GOES ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE. I KNOW
SAN JOSE DOES HAVE A JUST CAUSE.
.
KLAUS.
ORDINANCE.
.
IS A POINT OF CLARIFICATION DOES
THE BILL NOW REQUIRED THAT EVERY
CITY HAVE. JUST BECAUSE.
OR DOES IT LEAVE IT TO THE
CITIES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY WANT
TO ENACT A JUST CLAUSE
ORDINANCE.
THE BILL THAT THE COUPLE THINGS
ONE IT. IT HAS CLEAR LANGUAGE IN
SECTION DE INDICATING THAT THIS
BILL.
DOES NOT SUPERSEDE OR PREEMPT
ANY OTHER ANY LOCAL ORDINANCE SO
TO THE EXTENT SAN JOSE OR OTHER
CITIES DALY CITY ARE SO UNION
CITY ALREADY HAVE JUST BECAUSE
ORDINANCES THOSE REMAIN INTACT
UNTOUCHED BY. BY THIS THIS
MEASURE THIS MEASURE WOULD BE ON
THAT REQUIRE STATEWIDE THAT.
FOR ANY OF IT YOU NOTICE A COSBY
ARTICULATED IN THE NOTICE AND
THEN AFTER THAT IT SAYS THREE
THINGS.
ARE NOT BECAUSE FOR ADDICTION
BOB FOR FORECLOSURE CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP AND AND AND OF A OF A
FIXED TERM LEASE. UP SO IT IT'S
REALLY BARE BONES
BUT THE REQUIREMENT AND EXERCISE
THAT A LANDLORD ARTICULATE A
CAUSE FOR FICTION I THINK WILL
REALLY HELP NARROW. OBJECTIONS
TO TO FAIR AND JUST WANTS RATHER
THAN RETALIATORY OR
DISCRIMINATORY OR ARBITRARY OF
ACTIONS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT ALL TENANTS
ALL SEVENTEEN MILLION OF THEM IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENJOY. A THAT
THAT PROTECTION.
IT ALSO JUST SAYS THAT IN THREE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHICH WE
BELIEVE ARE OPTICALLY
CONTROVERSY THAT THOSE ARMED DO
NOT CONSTITUTE BECAUSE FOR AN
ADDICTION AND AFTER THAT EVERY
LOCALITY CAN CAN CAN DO NOTHING.
AT OR OR BUILD UP ON ON THIS
FOUNDATION AS MUCH AS THEY LIKE
IN MIDDLE BE UP TO UP TO THEM.
AND THEY MAY EVEN IF THEY LIKE
THAT DECIDE TO THE PAIR.
A JUST CAUSE ORDINANCE WITH
WITH RENT CONTROL.
SOMETHING THAT WAS ALLUDED TO
IN THE OPPOSITION AS AS A SORT
OF MORE OPTIMAL PROTECTION FOR
TEN BUT WE DIDN'T GO THERE
THAT'S UP FOR LOCALS TO DECIDE.
AND AND AND THEY MAY IF THEY
WISH.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MAY BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
I'M.
I WAS.
I HAVE SOME CONCERNS BUT I AM
GONNA BUT YOU SUPPORTING IT OUT
MAINLY BECAUSE AND. A WOMAN.
NAME CYNTHIA CALLED OUR OFFICE
AND.
.
SPOKE IN TOW HAULING YOUR MOM IS
A SUPPORTER OF YOUR BILL SPOKEN
TO COLLEAGUES MY STAFF AND KNEW
THE NUMBER OF FILIPINOS.
RENTERS AND FULL OF ESTA SO I
HAVE WITH THAT KIND OF ADVOCATES
SEE FROM YOUR MOM.
AND THIS CLOSE TO MOTHER'S DAY
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY.
AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE.
SEE THIS TO TO.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK MY
MOTHER TO CALL THAT SENATOR
THOUSANDS OPPOSITE XO GOT UP
BILL.
I HAVE A PICNIC.
OUR FIRST I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE CONVERSATION ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THERE'S ONE
THING IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS THAT
I THOUGHT WAS WAS INTERESTING IN
AND. OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
NOTED THAT THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATIONS THAT.
ARE ARGUING THAT JUST BECAUSE
ORDINANCES ARE LOCAL ISSUE THAT
SHOULD BE DECIDED BY INDIVIDUAL
CITIES.
ARE THE SAME ASSOCIATIONS THAT
HAVE SPONSORED AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE COSTA HAWKINS ACT.
WHICH APPLIES A STATEWIDE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL MANDATE TO TO
LIMIT RENT CONTROL.
AND I I THINK WE ALL APPRECIATE
SOME OF THE IRONY IN THAT.
BUT I I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS.
WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS TIME
TENANTS ARE EXPERIENCING THE
MOST INTENSE CRISIS.
EVER REALLY OUR STATE HISTORY
AND.
AND MY HOPE AND I WOULD ASK YOU
PART ASSOCIATION TO TO WORK WITH
US TO TRY TO CRAFT. TENET
LEGISLATION PROVIDE SOME RELIEF
BECAUSE FOR THOSE OF US WHO'VE
BEEN TRYING TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION IN THE ONGOING
DIALOGUE.
BUT AT THIS POINT BECAUSE OF
THE CONTINUED OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TO KEEP PUSHING. A TO TO DO WHAT
WE CAN AYE MY CITY IS ONE THAT
HAS EXPERIENCE JUST BECAUSE.
PROTECTIONS ARE CLEARLY THAT
HAS NOT HAMPERED.
THE RENTAL MARKET IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR ANOTHER CITIES THAT
WE'VE HAD AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS TO I
KNOW ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS.
I DO HOPE WE CAN GET THIS OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND CONTINUE THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND LOOK
FOR THAT AND HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION THAT AFFECT THANK YOU YOU
HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE.
THE PARTY MIKLOS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS COLLEAGUES AND AND
FEEL ENGAGE IN ON THIS ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHIU I CHIU AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
INSULTS WATCHER I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN NO
REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
STAFF SO I WILL NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
ONE TWENTY.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE
CERVANTES HAS ALSO BEEN PULLED
FROM OUR AGENDA TODAY WE WILL
HEAR THAT.
NEXT WEEK.
SO WE HAVE.
I DON'T SEE MISTER TING HERE
RESEARCH OUR YOU READY PRESENTS.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE.
CHAU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OUR FIRST OF ALL I WILL ACCEPT
OUT THE AMENDMENTS ON PAGES FIVE
AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
WILL REQUIRE CONSUMER CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCIES OR CCR RATES.
TO PATCH VULNERABLE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS WILL BE SUBJECT TO A
CIVIL LIVE A LIABILITIES AWARDED
TO INDIVIDUALS WHOSE DATA WAS
COMPROMISE.
AUG TWENTY SEVENTEEN EQUIFAX A
DATA BREACH RESULTED IN THE LOSS
OF HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION U. S. CONSUMERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
PRIOR TO THE BREACH TO YOU
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY NOTIFY
EQUIFAX.
OTHER COMPANIES ON MARCH TO A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OF THE NEED.
A PATCH SECURITY VULNERABILITIES
IN SOFTWARE CALL APACHE STRUTS.
HOWEVER THAT PATCH NEVER
OCCURRED. ARE CONSEQUENTLY
BETWEEN MAY THIRTEEN IN JULY
THIRTIETH TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HACKERS EXPLOITED.  THE
VULNERABILITY TO ACCESS
SENSITIVE INFORMATION INCLUDING
CONSUMER NAME SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS BIRTHDATES ADDRESSES AND
IN SOME CASES DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND ALSO CREDIT CARD NUMBERS
THIS BILL AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
WILL REQUIRE A CC ARE A. OF
CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA TO BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT
A PATCH OF IT'S A COMPUTER
SYSTEM WITHIN THREE DAYS.
AND THEN COMPLETE THE SOFTWARE
UPDATE WITHIN THE MOST EXPEDIENT
TIME POSSIBLE ARE CONSISTENT
WITH INDUSTRIES FOR OUR BEST
PRACTICES. BUT NO LONGER THAN
THIRTY DAYS.
IF IT IS SUBJECT TO A
VULNERABILITY THAT POSES A
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO THAT
SECURITY OF COMPUTERIZED DATA
CONTAINING PERSONAL INFORMATION.
IF A CCR A FAILED TO PASSED ITS
SYSTEM IN A DATA BREACH OCCURS.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW A RESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA WHOSE INFORMATION
WAS COMPROMISED
TO BRING A CIVIL ACTION TO
RECOVER DAMAGES
FOR HIS OR HER INJURIES ARE
CIVIL. PENALTIES AND ALSO
REASONABLE ATTORNEYS FEES AND
COSTS THAT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU IT WHEN IT SUPPORTS.
OH YEAH.
GOOD MORNING DANIELLE CANDLE
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
IS SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
MY IN GRAMMYS FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA AS THE ANNOUNCES
NOTES WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BELL WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED THEN THE ANALYSIS AND WE
CONTINUE. TO LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROTECTIONS
CONTEMPLATED BY THE BELL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RAINY POLIQUIN BEHALF
THE CONSUMER DATA INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
WHICH REPRESENTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
CONSUMER REPORTING AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING THE THREE NATIONAL
CREDIT BUREAUS.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR
MEETING WITH US TO DISCUSS YOUR
CONCERNS WITH THE LEGISLATION.
AS AN INDUSTRY WE TAKE SERIOUSLY
THE PREACHERS THAT OCCUR TO OUR
SYSTEMS AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
INVESTIGATION OF EQUIFAX BY THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION.
THE CONSUMER FINANCE PROTECTION
BUREAU AND CONGRESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO FURTHER UNDERSTAND
WHAT WENT WRONG AND TO ENSURE
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN BE
PREVENTED IN THE FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE GRAMM LEACH
BLILEY ACT REQUIRES COMPANIES TO
ENSURE THE SECURITY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AS PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE GOP ACT THAT TO SEE ISSUES
SAFEGUARD RULES WHICH REQUIRES
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS UNDER FTC
JURISDICTION TO HAVE MEASURES IN
PLACE. TO KEEP CUSTOMER
INFORMATION SECURE.
THE CREDIT REPORTING INDUSTRY
ALSO FOLLOWS GOOD BUSINESS
PRACTICES IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS
AND TECHNOLOGY AMONG OTHER
NATIONAL STANDARDS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
AS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
ALL THE CALIFORNIA CONSIDERS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THESE PRACTICES
AND ASSIST IN PREVENTING
PREACHES. RATHER THAN EXPOSING
OUR SYSTEM TO OTHER POTENTIAL
SECURITY VULNERABILITIES.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES IN THE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
EACH OF THE VULNERABILITIES HAVE
TO BE ASSESSED TO RISK AS WELL.
WE APPRECIATE THAT SOME WOMEN'S
WILLINGNESS TO FURTHER DISCUSS
PRIORITIZING OUR SECURITY RISK.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED WITH OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
THE CIVIC WAY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT WE SHALL BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT
A SOFTWARE UPDATES OR PATCH
WITHIN THREE DAYS.
WE BELIEVE.
THE WORD EMPLOYMENT NEEDS TO BE
FURTHER TO.
A FINE THE MEAN ASSETS A TO IT
ASSESS PLAN AND TEST
AS THAT IS A PROCESS THAT TAKES
PLACE BEFORE PATCH CAN BEGIN TO
BE IMPLEMENTED.
WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THERE
COULD BE GOT COMPLICATIONS
MANDATING A TIME FRAME THE
THIRTY DAYS WITHOUT FLEXIBILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IF WE FIND OUT
THAT A PACK OR SECURITY UPDATE
HAD THE BILL THE PROBLEM NAY NEW
PATCH OR UPDATE IS NOT READY AT
THAT TIME. I WAS STILL OBLIGATED
TO AND IT INSTALL THAT PATCH OR
UPDATE WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
IN ADDITION THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES IN A SOFTWARE UPDATE OUR
PATCH IS NOT OF THE APPROPRIATE
RECOURSE BUT UNDER THIS BILL IT
IS MANDATED.
FINALLY WHEN THE MOST TROUBLING
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL IS A
CIVIL PENALTY OF FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR EACH PERSON WHOSE
INFORMATION COULD BE POTENTIALLY
COMPROMISED WITHOUT SHOWING ANY
INJURY.
WHAT THE ANALYSIS STATED THAT
THIS AMOUNT WOULD BE REASONABLE
I WOULD SUGGEST OTHERWISE?
THINK ABOUT IT WHAT IF WE TAKE
THAT BUT FAX EXAMPLE.
AND TAKE TEN PERCENT OF THE
RECORD RELEASE SAYS CALIFORNIA
SHARE.
AND ONLY TEN PERCENT OF THOSE
PEOPLE FILE TO RECOVER THE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS WOULD AMOUNT TO A COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS OVER A QUARTER OF
EQUIFAX'S MARKET CAP.
THIS PROVISION HAS THE ABILITY
TO BANKRUPT COMPANIES.
SHOULD THE SAME STANDARD APPLIED
TO OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM CITY COUNTIES IN THE
STATE.
I WOULD THINK NOT BECAUSE THAT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AND BECAUSE
THEY WOULD HAVE TO EACH OF
THOSE.
THAT'S THE OF ORGANIZATION'S I
SHOULD STATE AND GOVERNMENT.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS AND OTHER
ACTIONS WHICH WE BELIEVE ARE THE
PROPER REMEDY.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STILL MUST
I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BUT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A
MEMBER IN TRYING TO RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
VERY BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR I'VE
BEEN ASKED BY THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I'M
MIKE BELOW TO INDICATE THEY ARE
OPPOSED WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THE CIVIL LIABILITY.
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
YOU SHOULD CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL
LET FILTER REPRESENTING
EXPERIENCE.
WITH SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT.
MISTER POLLOCK HAD.
.
STATED OF THIS VERY COMPLEX
AREA THINK WE ALL WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHALLENGE THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SINGH NANDA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SUCH I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE SWORD I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THAT. AND WITH
RESPECT TO.
SOME OF THE THE OPPOSITION KIND
OF LOOKING TO CONGRESS AND THE
FEDERAL.
AGENCIES TO HELP ADDRESS THIS
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE IN SOME
WAYS A LOT OF PROGRESS BEING
MADE THERE YET WE ARE LEFT IN
CALIFORNIA. TRYING TO PROTECT.
OUR OWN INDIVIDUALS AND AND
FOLKS WHO HAVE WHO HAVE SUFFERED
IN POTENTIALLY SUFFER
SIGNIFICANTLY.
FROM SOME OF THAT THE DATA
BREACHES AND OFTENTIMES
COMPANIES DON'T TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY TOO OFTEN THERE WAS A
PATCH OF.
WELL THAT WASN'T IMPLEMENTED
AND I'D.
I UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE BECAUSE
ARE OFTEN PATCHES THAT ARE QUITE
AS STABLE I WOULD HOPE COMPANIES
WOULD WOULD NOT RELEASED
SOFTWARE PATCHES THAT THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ADEQUATELY TESTED. BUT
IN AN ENTERPRISE ROUND THAT
OFTEN SOMETIMES IS AN ISSUE AND
SO MAYBE THERE IS THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE OR WERE WAYS
TO ADDRESS THAT IF A LARGE
ENTERPRISE.
DOES HAVE THE ABILITY TO.
TO TEST AND AND UNDERSTAND THAT
IF THEY ARE RAISING THAT ISSUE.
THE COMPANY RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
FOR THAT PATCH NEED TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY AND GET. A REPLACEMENT
IN AND AND ULTIMATELY SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM. BUT TO JUST IGNORE
UPGRADING SOFTWARE IS
APPROPRIATE TO NOT TAKE AN
APPROPRIATE STEP WHEN THERE'S AN
A A VULNERABILITY THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
SHOULD NO LONGER BE EXCUSABLE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT COMES UP
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AND IN THE
EQUIFAX ROUND WE KEEP LEARNING.
AND SO MANY COMPANIES THAT JUST
WANNA SAY LOOK THIS REALLY ISN'T
OUR PROBLEM AND FACT ARE
LOBBYING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NOW FOR COMPLETE COMMUNITIES?
FROM THESE KINDS OF THESE KINDS
OF BRIDGES AND YET THERE'S REAL
COST INDIVIDUALS TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. WHEN THERE'S A
BREACH AND THAT INFORMATION GETS
AROUND IT'S IT'S A VERY VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE BUT IT IS COMPLEX
AND.
AS
CHAIRMAN OF YOUR COMMITTEE I
KNOW THIS IS THAT YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY TAKING SERIOUSLY AND
AND WORKING ON.
NOT ANY EASY ANSWERS I'M HOPING
THAT THIS BILL DOES MOVE FORWARD
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
THAT THE DISCUSSION ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
RAISED HERE. AND WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA AS WE
SEEK TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS IN
A MUCH LARGER QUESTION AND A
MUCH LARGER PICTURE
SO I I APPRECIATE THIS BILL. AND
I DO HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
MOVE IT THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEE NOW I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
CHAU.
WITH A THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MISS CHAIR FOR YOUR COMMENTS AS
WELL ULTIMATELY ME CLOSE BY.
.
STATING THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION IN FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW I'M I'M OPEN TO
ON.
TWEETING OR FINE TUNING SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE INCLUDING THE WORD
IMPLEMENT I THINK THE INTENT
THERE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THE BALL ROLLING ONCE. ONCE
THE ENTITY FINDS OUT THAT
THERE'S OF ON ABILITY AND
THERE'S A FIX
TO GET THE BALL ROLLING WHETHER
IT'S THREE DAYS OR WHATEVER IT
THE DAY IT IS. ARE WE REMAIN
VERY FLEXIBLE ON SOME OF THE.
YOU KNOW THE SUGGESTIONS BEING
MADE THE REALITY IS THAT WE WE
HAVE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE IS INFORMATION THAT'S
BEING COMPROMISED. AND YES THERE
ARE A FEDERAL LAWS OUT THERE
THAT PROTECT US ALL CERTAIN ALL
INFORMATION BUT YET THERE'S NONE
OF THOSE LAWS ACTUALLY PERTAIN
TO APPLYING ANY PATCHES. AND
THERE'S NO TIMELINE AS WELL SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO TO FORCE
TO ESTABLISH SOME KIND OF TIME
LINE SAY THAT THE COMPANIES ARE
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A GOT YOU
KNOW BASICALLY SOME SOME.
YOU KNOW VERY HARD CRITERIA TO
THE BASICALLY BASICALLY TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW SO.
AND THEY ARE YOU KNOW AND IT
ALSO THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THERE
THAT SAYS THAT ONCE A
VULNERABILITY HAS HAS BEEN
DISCOVERED AND THEY. ARE THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO START ASSESSING
THE SITUATION SO THERE'S NO NEED
FOR HIM TO ACTUALLY START
IMPLEMENTING AND TOLD THEIR
SUSSMAN IS FINISHED WITH. SO
DOING GOT ASSESSMENT PERIOD THEY
COULD EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT
THAT PATCH IS ACTUALLY SUITABLE
OR APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR SYSTEM SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF OF THE WAY THERE
AS WELL SO PAY THE PROMISE IS
BASICALLY TO YOU ALL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION AND THEN
HOPEFULLY I WILL HAVE AYE ABOVE
FINAL A PRODUCT THAT'S.
ACCEPTABLE TO EVERYBODY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
TO TELL MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU AYE CHAU AYE CHIU.
IF YOU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU.
AS HE WAS SITTING MISTER
CUNNINGHAM ARE YOU READY YET TO
PRESENTS.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB THREE OH FOUR ONE
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB.
THIRTY FORTY ONE AND WITH ME
TODAY IS MISTER CHRISTOPHER
CARLISLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND.
AND LEXI HOWARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ESCROW ASSOCIATION.
PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES ARE
GENERALLY IMPOSED BY DEVELOPERS
AND THEY REQUIRE.
THE INITIAL
HOME THANK YOU PROTECT THEIR
HOME BUYER AND ALL SUBSEQUENT
PRECURSORS TO PAY A FEE UPON
TRANSFER. BASED ON A PERCENTAGE
OF THE SALE PRICE IN SOME AGREES
EXAMPLES.
THESE FEES CAN BE UP TO TWO
PERCENT OF PURCHASE PRICE OF A
HOMER SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOME TEN THOUSAND FOR FIVE AND
THOUSAND DOLLAR HOME.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE SEEING IS
UNDER FEDERAL LAW PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES THAT DO NOT.
PROVIDE A QUOTE UNQUOTE DIRECT
BENEFIT AS THAT PHRASE IS
DEFINED IN FEDERAL LAW.
CAN ACTUALLY DISQUALIFY BUYERS
FOR BEING ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
FREDDIE MAC.
THIS REDUCES OPPORTUNITY FOR
BUYERS AND CAN CAUSE VERY
UNWELCOME SURPRISES DURING
ESCROW.
FOR BOTH BUYERS SELLERS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY PROHIBIT
THE IMPOSITION OF PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE. A DIRECT BENEFIT AS THE
FINE IN FEDERAL LAW IT WILL LINE
CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY THREE
OTHER STATES THAT ALREADY
PROHIBIT THIS. BILL PROTECT
BUYERS AND SELLERS AND I'D LIKE
TO NOTE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT
UNDER TWELVES CFR TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT POINT ONE.
WHICH IS THE FEDERAL CODE THAT
DEFINES DIRECT BENEFIT.
A DIRECT BENEFIT.
DOES INCLUDE.
A CULTURAL EDUCATIONAL
CHARITABLE RECREATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND CONSERVATION
TYPE ACTIVITIES
SO I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE A
POSITION TODAY BUT I THINK THAT
FEDERAL LAW. AND DEFINITION
DIRECT BENEFIT ADDRESSES THE
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED TO US
PREVIOUSLY I THINK THIS BILL IS
VERY SUPPORTABLE AT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT CHRIS FOR CARLA WITH VIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS FOR STUFF I WANT TO
THANK YOUR.
CONSULTANT FOR THE VERY.
PLEASE ANALYSIS WITH REGARD TO
THE ISSUES RELATED TO A PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES.
LAST YEAR WE SPONSORED A BILL
WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN REYES TO
ALERT FOLKS TO THE FACT OF THE.
FEDERAL PROHIBITION ON.
GOVERNOR FINANCING FOR PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES THAT DID NOT
PROVIDE A DIRECT BENEFIT SOMEONE
CUNNINGHAM MENTIONED WHERE. YOU
CAN HAVE INSTANCES WHERE
SOMEBODY'S LOOKING TO BUY A
PLACE ONLY TO FIND THAT THEY
CAN'T GET FINANCING.
THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE IS WERE
YOU MAYBE HAVE AN ALL CASH BUYER
AND THEY COME IN WHEN THAT
INDIVIDUAL GOES TO SELL THEIR
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO. I THINK
ABOUT BEING A BLIND TO GET BYERS
BECAUSE THEIR BUYERS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET GOVERNMENT
FINANCING.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
BAN THESE ON A GO FORWARD BASIS
SO THIS WOULD BE ONLY FOR
PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES.
ESTABLISHED AFTER JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN.
BAND THOSE BECAUSE GOVERNMENT
FINANCING IS NOT AVAILABLE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT US PLEASE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEXI HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS ARE THE
ONES WHO MEET WITH BUYERS AND
SELLERS. WHEN THEY ARE SELLING
AND BUYING THE PROPERTY THEY ARE
ROUTINELY SURPRISED BY PRIVATE
TRANSFER FEES WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RAYOS.
LAST YEAR ON THIS WE THINK THAT
DOING THIS PROSPECTIVELY ADDS
PREDICTABILITY TO THE PROCESS IN
A WAY THAT IS APPROPRIATE AND
RESPECTFUL OF BUYERS AND
SELLERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
APPLAUSE THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION.
INSERT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M VICTORIA ROMAN WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WERE NOT IN OPPOSITION
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUST RAISE A
COUPLE CONCERNS. AND I DO
APOLOGIZE THAT WERE LATE TO THE
TABLE WE'VE ONLY JUST BEEN MADE
AWARE OF THE BILL. BUT.
WE WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
WORTH WERE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF
THE TO HONE CONSERVANCY
AGREEMENT WHICH WAS A LANDMARK
AGREEMENT BETWEEN. LANDOWNERS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
BUSINESSES TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
THE TELEPHONE RANCH DEVELOPMENT
MOVE FORWARD THAT THERE WAS
CONSERVATION OF THE SPECIAL.
IMPORTANT LANDS AROUND THE AREA
AND PART OF HOW THAT WAS FUNDED
WAS WITH PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES
AND MY UNDERSTANDING WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S NOT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT TO. COVER THAT
TYPE OF FEE I THINK THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AS OR TRYING TO.
CODIFY A FEDERAL RULING INTO
STATE LAW AND SO WE JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE. TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSULT WITH
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
AND OTHER CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND MAKE SURE THAT IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT IT'S NOT
INADVERTENTLY PROHIBITING THE
THAT TYPE OF FEET. EVEN THOUGH
IT IS PERSPECTIVE MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IS THAT AS A
HOME IS SOLD IN THIS.
DEVELOPMENT BUT THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED CREATED HAVING
CREATED A FEE AND SO COULD
PROHIBIT.
FEES EVEN IN THE TONE RANCH
AGREEMENT. GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
QUAN OF LET ME DONE WITHOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA ALSO VARIOUS.
.
BUT WE I'D LIKE PEOPLE.
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH.
MY COLLEAGUES AT.
.
THAT MY COLLEAGUE MADE WITH AN
RTC ALSO WANT TO BE.
MINDFUL THAT WE ARE LATE TO.
THE TABLE AND WANT ONE
APOLOGIZED NOT ONLY TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO TO THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS. LATE TODD CONCERNED WE
ARE NOT TAKING A POSITION TODAY.
WE WANT TO DO.
REGISTER CONCERNS ARE VERY
SIMILAR IN THE SAME VEIN THAT.
MISS OUR ROME.
SUGGESTED WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MITIGATION THAT MAY
OCCUR ON LANDS THAT ARE NOT
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT OR SERVICE.
SERVING THE FACTOR COMMUNITY
ARE AND IN SPECIFICALLY IT THAT.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL'S DEFINITION OF DIRECT
BENEFIT. OF THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
THE USE OF FEES TO BE USED FOR A
TO FIND ADDITIONAL MITIGATION.
YOU AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC SPECIFICALLY AS IT
RELATES TO OUR AREAS.
FOR.
VOLUNTARY MITIGATION OF PROGRAM
THAT WE OWE WE'VE HELPED US
CREATE LAST YEAR OR TWO YEARS
AGO ARE A WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT WOULD.
HELP CREATE.
MITIGATION IN AREAS THAT WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY BE ADJACENT TO.
YOU KNOW WHERE THE IMPACT IS
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THROUGH A LOT TO THAT
THROUGH THESE ISSUES. ARMED BUT.
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE WORK HERE LATER THAN.
WE WHAT I. WANTED TO REALLY
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THING THEN WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND JUST
EXPLAIN THE COMMITTEE WE HAD PUT
THIS ON CONSENT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS A BIT OF HISTORY. WITH THIS
ISSUE AND.
FOR MOST OF THESE FEES IT IT'S
REALLY THAT.
THE DEVELOPER WHO THEN CREATES A
STRUCTURE TO GET REIMBURSED OVER
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND THAT
BECOMES.
UNFAIR AND FUTURE BUYERS OF
THESE PROPERTIES WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT HE IS THERE
AND THAT THEY'RE PAYING INTO IT
THAT'S SORT OF. IN ITS WORST.
CONTEXT.
THAT FEDERAL LAW AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY CODIFYING A FEDERAL
PROGRAM HERE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
TRYING TO PROTECT AGAINST.
THESE KINDS A FEES CROPPING UP
AND HAVING THIS UNKNOWN
UNKNOWABLE.
PROCESS THAT NOW. WHEN DAY
TRANSACTION HAPPENS AND AND A
NEW HOME WAS FOR A HOME IS BEING
SOLD. THAT THAT FEE CROPS UP AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE'S THERE'S
AN OBLIGATION TO PAY. BUT
BECAUSE OF.
THE FEDERAL STATUTE I THINK THE.
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS IN THE IN
THE ISSUES OF FUNDING
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THIS BILL IS IS
ULTIMATELY GOING AFTER AN
ADDRESS BUT YOUR CONCERNS ARE
WELL TAKEN I THINK WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. TO ENSURE THAT WERE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT HOW THAT
HAPPENS ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED
IN THE PAST IS NOT REALLY OF
THIS IS PROSPECTIVE AND I
BECAUSE THAT STRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE IN THE HOME RANCH I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
THIS WOULD INTERFERE WITH WITH
AS THOSE HOMES OF SOUL BECAUSE
THAT'S AN OBLIGATION THAT.
RUNS ESSENTIALLY WITH AWAY AND
BUT IT'S WORTH ASKING THE
QUESTION AND IT'S WORTH
CLARIFYING AS WE MOVE THROUGH IT
AND SOME OF THE AUTHOR IS. FINE
WITH THAT BUT I JUST WANTED TO
EXPLAIN WHY. THIS WAS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE DON'T HAVE THE CITY'S
CROPPING UP BUT STILL ALLOW FOR.
WHAT THE FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS FOR
AND THAT IS TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
SOME BROADER COMMUNITY BENEFIT?
IN THROUGH MITIGATION FEES ARE
ONGOING MITIGATION FEES AS
PROPERTIES MOVE THAT'S WHAT WAS
CONTEMPLATED THAT'S A STRUCTURE
THINK WE WANT TO MAINTAIN A
THROUGH THROUGH BILL BUT THEN
GET RID OF THESE.
UNKNOWN.
WHERE THERE REALLY IS NO
COMMUNITY BENEFIT THERE'S NO
PUBLIC BENEFIT THERE'S NO IT'S
JUST SOMEBODY WHO WHO FIGURED
OUT HOW TO BUILD INTO THE
STRUCTURE?
BUY SELL THIS HOUSE AND IF
ANYBODY EVER CELLS THIS HOUSE
I'M GONNA GET SOMETHING IN MY
POCKETBOOK. THAT.
NO BE WOULD REASONABLY
UNDERSTAND.
SO THAT'S WHAT OF FULL LEYVA
LANDS AND. THAT THE OPPOSITION I
THINK OR. THE QUESTIONS ARE ARE
VALUABLE AND THEN MAKING SURE
THAT WE.
THAT THIS BILL IS IS IS
APPROPRIATE IN ITS CONSTRUCT BUT
THAT'S WHY THIS COMMITTEE THE
ANALYSIS IS WHAT IT IS I THINK
THIS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE BELL
JUST. CLEARING UP THE ISSUE ON
THE CITY'S IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD NEED TO DO BUT ALLAY THE
CONCERNS OF OF THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS THAT DERIVE FROM PAST
FEES AND AND HOW THAT STRUCTURE.
WE DON'T WANT TO FRUSTRATE
FEDERAL.
THE FEDERAL.
STRUCTURE THAT WAS PUT.
OTHER QUESTIONS HOUSE WAS THAT
YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIR I'M GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I WANNA JUST GIVE THE
AUTHOR AN OPPORTUNITY. NOW OR I
OR ANY OF THE SPONSORS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS OF BEEN RAISED I. I I
WOULD GUESS THAT THE AUTHOR DID
NOT HAVE ANY INTENT OF TRYING TO
UNDERMINE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
MEDICATIONS THAT WERE LAID OUT
IN.
IN THE PROPOSED PLAN THAT WAS
DISCUSSED.
OR TO IMPACT THOSE SORTS OF
ISSUES MORE BROADLY BUT IF YOU
COULD JUST TAKE A MOMENT AND
EXPLAIN YOUR INTENT AND AND AND
I KNOW YOU HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH.
WITH SOME OF THESE PARTIES TO
RESOLVE THE LANGUAGE SO IT
CLEARLY DOES DOES WHAT WE ALL
WANTED TO DO.
YES THANK YOU SO A COUPLE POINTS
ON THAT I DON'T THINK.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE WORRIED THAT
THIS IS THIS BILL WOULD IN ANY
WAY FRUSTRATE WHAT TOWN RANCHER
ANYBODY ELSE IS TRYING TO DO IN
TERMS OF.
CONSERVATION AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS. UP BECAUSE AT THE
FEDERAL STATUTE WHICH DEFINES
WELL REGULATION THAT THE FINES
DIRECT BENEFIT.
WE CAN'T REALLY.
ALTER THAT BECAUSE IF WE DO.
WE CHANGE THE LANGUAGE OF IT AND
STATE LAW WE COULD BE IN A
SITUATION OR FANNIE MAE AND
FREDDIE MAC ARE.
ARE NOT TAKING THAT IS VALID AND
THEN WE HAVEN'T CURED THE
PROBLEM AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT
HOME BUYERS AND SELLERS THAT OUR
UNSUSPECTING.
.
FIGURE OUT.
IN THE PROCESS THAT THEY CAN'T
QUALIFY FOR LENDING.
THAT'S BACKED BY BY FANNIE AND
FREDDIE SO BUT BUT THAT
DEFINITION.
IS IT IS.
IT'S PROVIDED OF DIRECT BENEFIT
INCLUDES ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION CONDUCTED IN OR
PROTECT THE BURNED COMMUNITY OR
ADJACENT CONTIGUOUS PROPERTIES I
DON'T THINK THE DEFINITIONS
COULD BE PROBLEMATIC FOR.
INCORPORATING SOME SORT OF.
EASE MENTOR WHATEVER IT WOULD BE
THAT RUNS WITH THE LAND THAT.
PROVIDES FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF
A COMMUNITY PARK FOR EXAMPLE OR
CONSERVATION OF OPEN SPACE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I I I DON'T
THINK I APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS
I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS.
RAISING THAT BUT I I DON'T
THINK.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY SIMPLY TRYING
TO DO IS?
EXACTLY WHAT THE CHAIR SAID AS.
BAN PRIVATE TRANSFER FEES IN
CALIFORNIA.
LIKE FORTY OF THE FORTY THREE
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE. THAT ARE
ESSENTIALLY JUST DEFERRED PROFIT
FOR BUILDERS
THAT THEY GET TWO PERCENT OF THE
SALE.
IN PERPETUITY EVERYTIME
THE THE PROPERTIES TURNED OVER.
AND THERE'S REALLY THAT DOESN'T
GO TO ANYTHING THAT'S BENEFICIAL
FOR ANY HOMEOWNER AND REALLY
WHAT WE'RE SEEING AND. AS I GOT
INTO THIS ISSUE AND STUDY THAT I
THINK IT'S A.
IT IT'S A PRETTY BIG PROBLEM.
IN TERMS OF.
PROTECTING BUYERS AND SELLERS.
AND THEN I THINK THE WITNESS HAD
SOME COMMENTS ON THE IDEA I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT THE BILL OF
SPEAKS TO A PUBLIC TRANSIT FEES
ESTABLISHED.
AFTER JANUARY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN.
NOW I THINK THE POINT THAT THE
OPPONENTS OF RAISING IS AS NOT
LAWRENCE. WELK THAT'S RIGHT
CONCERNS THAT CERTAIN FATTY
FOODS.
WHERE?
?
AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CAN EVEN
POINT OUT THESE THINGS OPERATE
IN PERPETUITY SO I THINK WHAT I
HEAR BEING SAID IS THAT WHEN.
THIRD GENERATION FOR GENERATION
IS THAT BEING ESTABLISHED A NEW.
AND IF WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU KNOW IT'S
ESTABLISHED AT THE OUTSET AND
THEN EVERY TIME THAT YOU HAVE A
SALE THAT'S NOT REESTABLISHED.
IT IT GOES BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
DATE. THAT MAKE SOME SENSE YEAH
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT YEAH YEAH THAT IF AND
IF WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT.
OKAY AND
YEAH BUT I JUST CLARIFY I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE IS THAT TO HONE
RANCHES
YOU NO PHASE DEVELOPMENT AND SO
SOME OF THE HOMES HAVE EVEN BEEN
BUILT YET. SO IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF THE RESALE IT'S THE FACT THAT
AS THEY ARE SOLD WITH THIS
IMPACT
FEET RIGHT AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT FEE IS TIED TO A
SPECIFIC DATE.
PRIOR TO THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
SO THAT PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
BEFOREHAND SO EVEN IF THAT
PROPERTY WHICH IS SUBJECT TO THE
FEE GET SUBDIVIDED AND SO THAT
PROGRAM IS IS ALREADY IN PLACE
BUT EVEN STILL BECAUSE OF THE
BENEFIT. I'M NOT SURE THAT. THIS
BILL WOULD APPLY IN THAT CASE
EVEN IF IT IS SET UP BUT THAT'S
A QUESTION.
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION AND
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
YOU GET SATISFIED.
I THINK WE'RE PRETTY I THINK
WERE OKAY I THINK MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SPILL THINGS ARE TO
BE OUT OF THE DRESSING THAT'S
ABOUT WHAT. WE.
IT'S WORTH MAKING SURE. WITH IT
AS LONG AS WE DON'T FRUSTRATE
THE OVERALL PURPOSE OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT I THINK
I THINK. THOSE CONCERNS ARE.
ARE VALID AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
LOOK AT THE SPECIFIC CASE THAT
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT MY THINK
ROCCA.
OR OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SIGNUP LISTA CUNNINGHAM YOU MAKE
CLOTHES I RESPECT WESTERN AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU TO MISTER
CHAIR THAT COMMITTEE STAFFER
REALLY GREAT WORK ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION HIS DO
PASS KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE. CUNNINGHAM
AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU BY CONSULT FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KILEY. KILEY I'D MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
WITHOUT.
THAT PHYLLIS OUT THAT BRINGS US
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE AJ ARE
THIRTY SIX
TO TAKE.
THANK YOU THERE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
THAT WE ADOPT THE RESOLUTION AS
AMENDED.
YOU TING WELCOME.
THANK MISTER CHAIR.
.
VERY BRIEFLY AJ ARE THIRTY SIX
RECOGNIZES MAY SIX. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS A HUNDRED THIRTIES
CONVERSE WITH THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT. AS WE ALL KNOW.
IF WE DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'VE
BEEN IT'S HARD TO KNOW WHERE
WE'RE GOING AYE GIVEN THE
CONTEXT OF. THE MUSLIM BAND
IMMIGRATION BANDS IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE ONLY TIME IN US
HISTORY WHERE WE ACTUALLY BANNED
THE IMMIGRATION.
OF A PARTICULAR GROUP BY
ETHNICITY AND WE JUST WANT TO
ENSURE AND REMIND CALIFORNIANS
HOW DANGEROUS THE DIALOGUE AT%
THE ANTI IMMIGRANT DIALOGUE IS
TODAY. PA AND TO BE VERY MINDFUL
OF THAT AND WHAT IT'S WHAT IT'S
LED US TO DO IN THE PAST ABOUT
WITH THAT I HAVE LA ONE VERY
VERY. PATIENT WITH THE NEW
WITNESS THE HEARTACHE FROM THE
BACK CALIFORNIA HISTORICAL
SOCIETY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
CHAIRPERSON STONE A MEMBERS OF
THAT COMMITTEE.
ANTHEA HER TAVY EXECUTOR TO THE
CALIFORNIA CIRCLE SOCIETY ON
BEHALF OF OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES
IN OUR STUFF I'M DEEPLY HONORED.
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TAINTS AJ ARE THIRTY SIX.
THE DESIGNATION OF SIXTH OF MAY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MARKING THE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
ANNIVERSARY OF PRESIDENT
AUTHORS.
SIGNING OF A CHINESE EXCLUSION
ACT IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATION'S REMEMBRANCE OF
A HEINOUS TARGETED. RACIALLY
MOTIVATED STAIN ON OUR STE
NATION'S HISTORY.
CALIFORNIA REGRETTABLY TOOK
BELIEVE IN THIS RACIAL TARGETING
THAT RESULTED IN THE UNJUST
DENIAL OF CHINESE AMERICANS
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
PROHIBITING THEIR PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
IMPORTANTLY THEIR RESISTANCE TO
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT GIVES
US HOPE AS IT WAS BRAVE
STRATEGIC AND SUSTAINED AS AS
OURS.
THE FACT THAT OUR CURRENT
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION HAS
ISSUED MULTIPLE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
TARGETING SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ESPECIALLY THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY. ONCE AGAIN PUTS US AS
A NATION ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
HISTORY.
THE LINK BETWEEN RACIAL AND
RELIGIOUS ANIMOSITIES THAT DRIVE
THE PRESIDENT'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS.
AND THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS DIRECT
AND IRREFUTABLE.
AJ ARE THIRTY SIX RIGHTFULLY
CALLS ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO REPEAL THESE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS. AND RESTORE
THE NATION'S MORAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL COR. AGAIN ITS
CITY PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY SIX AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL THAT
YOU DO.
THANK YOU ENLISTING JUST BE
CLEAR THEIR AMENDMENTS YOUR
ACCEPTING THOSE ABOUT THAT
STUFF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MISS CHIU JUST A
VERY QUICK COMMENT I WANT TO
THANK MY A COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOUR. AUTHORED THIS I
REPRESENT THE OLDEST CHINATOWN
IN OUR COUNTRY.
IN SAN FRANCISCO'S CHINATOWN
AND HE REPRESENTS OUR WEBSITE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE WASN'T LONG
AGO THAT THERE WERE. A ANTI
CHINESE RACIAL PROPERTY
COVENANTS THAT PREVENTED SOMEONE
LIKE PHIL TING FROM ACTUALLY
OWNING PROPERTY IN THE WEST SIDE
OF SAN
ISCO. ARE OBVIOUSLY THIS IS VERY
TIMELY GIVEN WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE NATIONAL CLIMATE TENDA.
APPRECIATED WHAT SUPPORT PART.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
AND THOSE WHO THINK THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WILL
NOTE THE FIRST CHINESE VILLAGE
ON THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA WAS
IN PACIFIC GROVE WHO'S A CHINESE
FISHING VILLAGE. WE THINK OF
MONTEREY HAVING BEEN.
A FISHING VILLAGE ESTABLISHED BY
ITALIAN IMMIGRANTS IT WAS
ACTUALLY CHINESE AND THEY BOTH
RECENTLY HAVE FOUND SOME
EVIDENCE OF THAT VILLAGE.
AND PART OF THE REASON THAT IT
SEEMS NEW AND PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WAS BECAUSE OF THE
REPRESSION.
OF THAT INFORMATION AND THEY
WERE NOT ALWAYS WELCOME BUT
THERE ARE NUMBER DESCENDANTS OF.
THOSE CHINESE FISHERMEN WHO CAME
ALL THE WAY OVER TO THE MONTEREY
BAY AND STARTED THE FISHING
INDUSTRY THAT. HAS GONE THROUGH
A LOT OF CHANGES OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS SO THAT THE
HISTORY IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF.
THE CHINESE WHO DID COME OVER TO
THIS COUNTRY EVEN EARLIER THAN
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT.
ARE ARE VERY NOTABLE SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THINKING MAKES EVEN MORE PROUD
TO HAVE GOTTEN MARRIED THE
PACIFIC GROVE.
SO THERE YOU VERY. FEW ALRIGHT.
THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THING YOU MAKE LOVE WITH THAT I
RESPECT FAST TRACK VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SPEED UP
AS AMENDED THE ROYALTIES STONE
BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU CHOW AYE CHU CHU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE.
THAT IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALRIGHT EVERY.
EVERYBODY WAS OUT WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYTHING ON CALL SO LET'S GO
BACK THROUGH THE ITEM FOR
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ON.
STARTING WITH CONSENT.
CALL THE AUTHOR MEMBERS.
CHU CHU I GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE CHAU.
OKAY WE'RE MISSING MISTER
CUNNINGHAM THAT'S ALL ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWO ZERO SEVEN
THREE CUNNINGHAM HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
SEVEN
EVERYBODY I'VE EVER FOR WAS
PULLED ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO LEVINE.
CHIU.
TO I GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH THREE LEVEL.
CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE BONTA.
WE HAVE EVERYBODY I REMEMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
FIVE.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM NUMBER NINE WE JUST DID.
OUR MISSING MISTER KILEY.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A.
B. THREE ZERO FOUR ONE
CUNNINGHAM.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
WE HAVE BEEN MISTER.
KILEY SCULLY THAT
.
SO IT'S CUNNINGHAM.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY NINE CHILD.
CUNNINGHAM NO.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO ZERO
SEVEN THREE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I..
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH THREE LEVEL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AJ ARE THIRTY
SIX TING.
CUNNINGHAM I.
AND THEN SIXTEEN IS YOUR SO.
RIGHT I THINK. THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED